bonjour à tous mercredi les sénateurs de
la mission commune d'information sur le
sport professionneles et les
collectivités territoriales ont organisé
une table ronde consacrée à la diffusion
du sport pour cela ils ont auditionné
différents directeurs des sports de
plusieurs chaînes de télévision TF1
Eurosport France télév vision bin sport
au cœur de leur question bien d'abord la
question des droits bien sûr alors
comment sont calculés ces droits comment
ces droits sont-ils ensuite répartis
pour financer les équipements sportifs
et les équipements sportifs sont-ils
adaptés à la diffusion télévisuelle
toutes ces questions ont été posées lors
de cette table ronde qui date de
mercredi et qui se déroulait en salle
clémenau la position des des diffuseurs
n'est pas toujours la même il y a pas
unanimité dans la demande entre euh les
chaînes thématiques de sport et les
chaînes événementielles comme nous TF1
on n'est pas exactement dans les mêmes
disposition des on n'a pas exactement
les mêmes requêtes euh que les
diffuseurs de chaîes thématique qui eux
j'allais dire vivent essentiellement de
retransmission euh des compétitions
sportives nous nos nos requêtes euh je
dirais qu'elles sont assez simples par
rapport au au vendeurs et par rapport
aux acteurs du sport c'est
effectivement sans entrer dans le détail
de disposer
d'installation
convenable dans un pays où c'est vrai
depuis longtemps ces installations ne
sont pas forcément à la hauteur de
celles qui peuvent
être vu en Grande-Bretagne mais je pense
que là c'est une question plus politique
que directement matérielle c'est les
anglais sont des sportifs est-ce que les
Français sont des sportifs au sens
anglais du terme ça mpatas c'estàd que
nous sommes on vient de le voir là aux
Jeux Olympiques des sportifs
marseillaises c'est-à-dire que s'il y a
une Marseillaise au bout nous sommes
sportif si euh
elle n'y est pas on n'est pas forcément
dans les mêmes dispositions les Anglais
vivent pour et par le sport un anglais
moyen don dont le niveau de vie est
inférieur à un Français moyen ne va pas
au restaurant ne va pas forcément au
cinéma du lundi au samedi il attend le
match et donc le sport là-bas est un
enjeu très différent c'est une c'est une
manière de vivre donc lorsque vous voyez
les installations des clubs de 2e ou 3e
division anglaise je m'en étais aperçu
lorsque nous diffusions la Coupe
d'Angleterre de football c'est quelque
chose qui qui vaut le Parc des Princes
et encore en mieux donc on est sur des
comparaisons qui sont inutiles de de
faire on fera on se ferait du mal
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a un effort de
privatisation des club en même temps des
des stades mais il y a un enjeu
politique je veux dire avant que le
stade municipal de Marseille Devi une
Arena privée il fa faudrait que le ma en
soit d'accord et ça c'est pas évident
parce que l'argument politique de
posséder un stade municipal à Marseille
n'est pas n'est pas indifférent au maire
actuel ni au prochain maire si s'ils en
changent par
ailleurs le naming c'estàd l'attribution
de nom de société au stade est un peu
délicat en France où par chance on avait
encore cette poésie d'avoir des stades
qui s'appelaient du nom de grands
résistants ou encore Marcel ou rouourou
alors effectivement rouourou ça fait pas
tellement vendre
euh c'est c'est c'est une habitude qui
n'est pas du tout française et je vois
que je lisais encore ce matin que le
président du Racing rugby a bien du mal
à à vendre un nom mais tout ça c'est le
départ tout ça vient au départ
c'est-à-dire nous ne sommes pas un pays
de sportif au sens anglosaxon du terme
et on veut appliquer des méthodes
anglo-saxones ou ou ou allemandes
à à à nos à nos problèmes je pense qu'on
fait une erreur où on veut aller trop
vite peut-être c'est possible c'est
possible tout comme par exemple la
Fédération Française de RBY veut
construire un stade parce que la
Fédération anglaise a un stade de
tckenam le seul problème c'est que la
Fédération anglaise a acheté ce stade il
y a un siècle et sans doute pas au prix
où elle l'aurait acheté aujourd'hui et
autour de ce stade elle a construit tout
un environnement hôtelier de
restauration et cetera dans ce stade est
rentabilisé depuis pratiquement le début
du 20e siècle donc on est dans un
la comparaison la vraie comparaison
entre un peuple sportif et un peuple qui
l'a moins c'est vraiment la
Grande-Bretagne et nous et donc
s'inspirer des méthodes anglaises pour
dire il faut faire c il faut faire ça il
faut le faire avec beaucoup
de beaucoup de patience il faut pas
aller trop vite et il faut il faut
encore que ensuite les compétitions le
mérit qui est un autre un autre
problème le problème si on prend le
problème du sport principal qui est le
rugby qui est le
football c'est que on est entré dans une
compétition où
effectivement un certain nombre
d'installations vont être nécessaire
mais en même temps il y aura une telle
différence entre les deux clubs leaders
et les autres que la compétition va
pouvoir se résumer souvent comme en
Grande-Bretagne ou en Espagne o on sait
jamais si c'est Barcelone ou Madrid qui
va être champion mais sûement par
quelqu'un d'autre ou alors vraiment par
le plus grand des hasards donc est-ce
que ça vaut le coup d'investir lorsqu'on
est sûr de ne être qualifié pour une
compétition européenne qui vous rapporte
une certaine somme ça c'est un problème
qui qui risque de se poser donc voilà
autant d'éléments qui alors ensuite si
vous voulez on parlera des problèmes qui
nous sont posés en terme de diffusion
dans les contrats qui sont passés
actuellement les problèmes de prix de la
diffusion sont souvent imposés par le
vendeur je dis je disait à mes amis FL
rouso qui est à mes côté qui a travaillé
à mes côtés le sa j'ai dans mon bureau
le contrat du tournoi des 5 nations 1976
qui fait à peu près 30 lignes écrites
par Roger couder et le et le directeur
financier de la Fédération Française ri
il fait 30 lignes écrites à la main il
est parfait il y a une tâche de gras en
bas on voit que ça a été fait au
restaurant mais pour le reste il est il
est parfait aujourd'hui le même contrat
fait à peu près 150 pages parce que les
vendeurs ont des exigences en terme de
production qu'on ignore souvent parce
que souvent on parle simplement du prix
des droits les droits sont chers mais
l'année dernière par exemple nous avons
été obligés nous pour des raisons de de
de température d'annuler un match
France-Irlande de de rugby et on m'a
posé la question de savoir combien ça
m'avaitcouté bah 130000 € de production
130000 € de production et j'en avais
fait et jeavais fait qu'appliquer les
normes imposées par le vendeur pour
telle et telle catégorie de match vous
avez tel nombre de de caméras
obligatoire tel nombre de loupes
obligatoire tel nombre de ralentis
obligatoire et cetera et cetera et
cetera et CEA et cetera donc en fait
effectivement nous nous cherchons aussi
à faire le mieux possible mais beaucoup
de ces critères nous sont imposés euh
par les vendeurs au moment de de de
l'achat des droits donc c'est ce qui
renchérit encore le coût de la diffusion
du sport sur les chaînes françaises
parce que nous avons des exigences qui
chaque année sont au top de la des
nouveautés techniques et qui nous qui
nous pose des problèmes parce que nous
n'avons même plus le temps je dirais de
rentabiliser les les les matériels que
nous achetons euh parce qu'entre la HD
et cetera il faut passer de la HD après
il faut passer
bientôt voilà encore il faut c'est c'est
tous les ans quoi tous les ans bon donc
voilà voilà grosso modo la la situation
telle que je la vois c'est c'est pas que
je je
sois pessimiste parce que je pense
que les choses mais je pense que le le
temps sera nécessaire et un événement
comme l'euro de de de 2016 oui c'est un
événement qui qui qui va sans doute
booster un certain nombre de de clubs
pour améliorer leurs installations si
elles ont été choisies comme stade de
référence pour ces compétitions là alors
ensuite
euh est-ce que le financement doit en
être privé ou financer par mes impôts ça
c'est une question qui qu'il faut se
poser aussi je veux dire que vous ne
pouvez pas empêcher quelqu'un de penser
que faire un rapport entre le salaire
que peut toucher un joueur et et et
l'augmentation de la taxe d'habitation
qu'on va lui demander pour rénover le
stade enfin moi je me poserai la
question honnêtement
euh j'aurais plutôt envie que tout ça
soit privé parce que si c'est je je je
ferai un rapprochement qui est je ferai
un mélange qui est qui est sans intérêt
mais j'aime beaucoup les mélanges parce
que les gens font des mélanges et ils
ont raison de faire des mélanges eux
pour eux euh avoir une taxe d'habitation
très importante et savoir que bien sûr
ça va servir bien sûr à réparer le stade
mais aussi à payer les joueurs au prix
où ils sont payés lui il va il va pas
hésiter à trouver ça peut-être un peu
fort de café en S simple citoyen je
pense qu'il auraiit pas forcément tort
voilà grosso modo j'espère je sais pas
si mes confrères seront d'accord avec
moi mais enfin voilà grosso modo les les
les problèmes qui sont qui nous sont
posé
quotidiennement merci je salue l'arrivée
de Stéphane Mazard notre rapporteur je
laisse la parole à V Monsieur François P
donc directeur délégué de tfin
production en charge des
sports bonjour Je je rejoins euh en
effet ce que vient de dire Daniel
Bilalan
sur je dirais le déjà le le schéma un
peu économique et de du du marché
audiovisuel il y a je pense qu'il y a
deux deux types de diffuseurs
aujourd'hui qui sont les diffuseurs
gratuits comme France Télévision et et
TF1 et puis les diffuseurs payants je
crois que ce sont deux offres bien
distincte nous c'est vrai que pour faire
un petit rappel de ce que fait le groupe
aujourd'hui on a depuis 3 4 ans 3 4 ans
tendance à se recentrer sur les grands
événements sportifs en terme de
diffusion que ce soit la Coupe du monde
de football ou de rugby euh parce que ce
sont des des éléments fortement des
événements fortement fédérateurs
d'audience que nous recherchons euh et
tout ça dans un contexte
économique complexe à la fois en de
droit c'est vrai que les sujets qui sont
proposés aujourd'hui sont assez vastes
donc on parle à la fois des droits et
des et des sites sur lesquels se passent
les les événements en terme de droit les
les droits ont ont tendance à augmenter
de manière assez exponentielle et c'est
vrai qu'on est obligé évidemment nous de
faire des
arbitrages dans un contexte économique
général difficile dans un paysage
audiovisuel qui a beaucoup bougé donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a bien une
distinction entre les chaînes gr
gratuite à audience je dirais grand
public et national et les chaînes
payantes thématiques qui s'adressent aux
fans
euh et au aux supporters fans de fans de
fans de sport qui vont payer un
abonnement pour poursivre différentes
compétitions
euh et on l'a vu dernièrement euh c'est
vrai que des compétitions récurrentes
comme la Ligue des champions de football
ou la Formule 1 qui a été diffusée sur
TF1 euh nous ne pouvons plus
aujourd'hui avoir accès et permettre
surtout au téléspectateurs d'avoir accès
à ces à ces compétitions donc je crois
que la distinction est vraiment
importante et elle est à prendre en
compte dans nos réflexions et et dans
l'analyse de la relation entre le le
sport professionnel et les et les
chaînes de télévision aujourd'hui après
d'un point de vue plus
opérationnel je dirais que en effet nous
nous sommes
souvent mis un petit peu devant le fait
accompli sur des contrats qui sont
signés avec des ayant droit c'est
souvent d'ailleurs sont souvent des
appels d'offre qui se passent de manière
un peu unilatérale parce que ils sont
souvent assortis de de conditions
importantes on met beaucoup d'argent
mais on nous impose aussi pas mal de
choses dans ce type de contrat donc on a
peu de nous peu de marge de Man œuvre du
côté des des acheteurs euh et les
stades sont plus ou moins adapté à la
diffusion et à la
production audiovisuelle on le voit même
sur certains stades neuf les les
équipements sont pas toujours adaptés à
nos besoins de
production il y a certains stades dans
lesquel on peut pas faire rentrer un
smirmorque c'est ça paraî idiot mais on
n pense pas nécessairement au moment
construit le stade et pourtant c'est une
obligation pour pouvoir diffuser un
match aujourd'hui à la télé euh les
position des caméras alors après on
rentre dans des
conflits entre la billetterie entre euh
d'autres types de d'organ de presse que
ce soit presse écrite radio qui n'ont
pas les mêmes besoins que la télé donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
paramètres qui devrai être pris en
compte qui le sont peut-être pas
suffisamment en amont en
l'occurrence Daniel parlait de du stade
du futur stade de rugby on a été
interrogé on a été un peu consulté sur
voilà la manière dont et quels étaient
nos besoins est-ce que ce sera pris en
compte je n'en sais j'en sais rien mais
au moins on a eu le mérite d'être d'être
interrogé et c'est c'est assez assez peu
souvent le le cas donc donc voilà c'est
un peu aujourd'hui je crois les les
différents sujets qui sont un peu
éloignés les un des autres quand même
parce que c'est c'est un sujet assez
assez vaste euh nous euh encore une fois
voilà notre notre seul objectif c'est
de d'offrir à nos téléspectateurs le
plus beau spectacle possible donc ça
passe à la fois par des droits qui
doivent être accessibles mais aussi par
des conditions de de travail et de
production qui qui soient les plus
adaptés à nos
métiers merci euh je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur Florant ouo directeur
de la rédaction de BN sport bonjour
monsieur le Président effectivement je
suis aussi un peu d'accord avec mes mes
collègues et confrères sur la
distinction entre les diffuseurs
gratuits et les diffuseurs payants
sachant que les diffuseurs gratuits
aujourd'hui s'orientent de plus en plus
comme le disait Daniel et et François
sur des événements des grands événements
de sport qui ne sont pas du du coup
récurrentss sont des événements qui ont
lieu une fois tous les ans ou une fois
tous les 4 ans euh il faut noter que
depuis 2 ans avec l'arrivée de BeIn
Sport et donc un concurrent sur le
terrain du du payant on va dire ne peut
être qu'une bonne une bonne chose pour
le sport puisque le les budgets des
clubs ne se font pas seulement sur un
événement annuel il y a toute une
récurrence de feuilletons dans l'année
qu'on peut parler du football on peut
parler du basket puisqueaujourd'hui bien
sport diffuse pas loin de 15 15
compétitions différentes 15 disciplines
différentes alors évidemment la vitrine
c'est le le football parce que sans vous
sans football vous pouvez pas diffuser
du basket ou du volleyball ou en tout
cas vous avez pas la même audience avec
un catalogue de droit et donc un une une
programmation assez riche en football
vous attirer derrière pourquoi pas des
téléspectateurs qui étaient pas habitués
à regarder du basket ou du ou du hand ou
du volleyball c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui sur bean sport qui diffuse
vous parliez tout à l'heure de l'exemple
de nanter en en Ligue des champions de
de de hande et à la fois l'urolag de
basket ces disciplines là sont diffusées
aujourd'hui sur BeIn Sport et à travers
les droits que bean sport verse ou à des
fédés ou à des ligues ou à des
organisateurs internationaux contribu à
financer une partie des budgets des
clubs et là effectivement nanter mais
également le Paris handbal qui
aujourd'hui n'a pas de salle digne pour
recevoir une compétition et accueillir
des clubs qui viennent jouer la Ligue
des champions de hand est obligé
d'annexer la salle de à le Carpentier
avec une harmonisation de calendrier
entre le l'équipe de basket de nanre qui
joue dans cette même salle donc des
problèmes de programmation des des cas
horaires qui du coup ne sont pas
forcément adaptés à la fois au
diffuseurs et et au public donc je pense
qu'il est effectivement on va dire
urgent que les différents intervenants
du monde du sport que ce soit le
politique le vendeur d'un événement le
club mais aussi les diffuseurs se
mettent effectivement autour d'une table
et mais dès le départ l'exemple
effectivement de d'un stade on prend
l'exemple du stade de Lille par exemple
puisque nous au moment du lancement de
be on a fait et on a diffusé le premier
match du du du losque dans la nouvelle
enceinte euh personne n'a été sollicité
évidemment au départ et dès le départ il
y a un problème majeur puisque la zone
technique ne reçoit pas ne serait-ce que
les liaisons Internet ou GSM donc à
partir de là déjà donc dès la conception
d'un stade dès la réflexion sur
l'architecture d'un stade le
positionnement là on parle de des
liaisons GSM ou téléphone ou internet
mais même en terme de lumière par
exemple euh c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut rentrer donc je pense que c'est dès
le départ euh on a beaucoup de retard
tout à l'heure Daniel comparait la
France à l'Angleterre il y a évidemment
des choses intéressantes à prendre
partout ce mais je pense que il faut le
faire par étape des grands événements
comme l'Euro 2016 on peut dire qu'on a
eu aussi la Coupe du monde en 98 donc on
a déjà obtenu des choses qui ont permis
de faire avancer les infrastructures de
football le vrai problème en France
n'est pas sur le football entre
guillemets les plus gros problèmes sont
sur les autres sports le basket parfois
le rugby pour certains stades même même
en au niveau de la Ligue 2 aujourd'hui
bein diffuse avec Eurosport
l'intégralité des matchs de Ligue 2 et
parfois on a effectivement des des
difficultés à produire et des qu'on dit
difficulté à produire c'est coût
supplémentaires donc coût de production
supplémentaire donc donc on peut aussi
dire moins de financement dans dans les
droits par exemple puisqueà un moment
donné si une chaîne de télé paye
100 au niveau des droits mais doit
rajouter systématiquement et ça beaucoup
de gens l'oublient parfois 30 ou 40 pour
mettre des moyens de production et
produire cet événement et le diffuser et
ben je pense que si tout le monde autour
de la table suffisamment tôt essaie de
trouver un modèle qui permettent à la
fois d'avoir des structures plus
adaptées pour le public pour les chaînes
de télé c'est quelque chose d'important
il faut à mon avis commencer par
là
merci la parole à Monsieur donc arnaau
Simon directeur général de rosp France
Monsieur le Président Monsieur les
sénateurs merci cette invitation et
d'avoir l'occasion de effectivement de
de parler ces sujets qui nous qui nous
touchent au au
quotidien juste peut-être un petit mot
d'introduction sur Eurosport doncosport
est d'abord un groupe international qui
est détenu ou qui va l'être dans
quelques semaines à 51 % par le groupe
américain Discovery et à 49 % par mon
collègue ici présent représentant
TF1 Eurosport c'est une sorte de de
miracle permanent puisque c'est presque
120 millions de foyers qui reçoivent la
chaîne Eurosport dans toute l'Europe
dans 54 pays 22 langues donc ça sera
l'occasion peut-être à certain moment
d'avoir un éclairage aussi sur ce qui
peut se passer dans dans d'autres
territoires sur la France
Eurosport est une une chaîne que je
qualifierai par trois trois
adjectifs populaire généraliste et
accessible populaire parce qu'on est la
marque de sport de chaîne thématique la
plus la plus reconnue c'est 9 millions
de foyers donc c'est énorme pour une
chaîne une chaîne payante accessible
parce qu'elle est peu chère c'est
quelques dizaines de centimes d'euros
pour s'abonner à Eurosport dans dans le
cas d'un bouquet basique auprès de
différents opérateurs ce qui d'ailleurs
fait penser beaucoup de gens qui ont r
sport depuis longtemps qu'il la payent
pas euh sauf que si c'est quand même
c'est quand même une chaîne payante qui
a qui a cette réalité économique
généraliste je pense qu'on y reviendra
euh parce que nous on est très attaché à
évidemment parler football évidemment
par les rugby mais pas que euh c'est
tout le ski qu'on retransmet aussi tous
les hivers ce sont les sports mécaniques
euh c'est aussi dans dans le sens
populaire il y a le sens profondeur et
là je peux vous dire que la
problématique des stades euh on la
touche vraiment de on on la on la reçoit
de de plein fouet quand par exemple vous
diffusez la Coupe de France de football
bah là nécessairement vous vous êtes
obligé de vous adapter aux éléments si
vous allez au Sablé sur sartte si vous
allez dans des dans des dans les petites
villes qui vivent ça comme une fête mais
qui n'ont pas forcément l'habitude
d'accueillir cette compétition mais vous
êtes obligé de vous adapter donc ça
c'est aussi peut-être quelque chose
qu'on un point sur lequel on pourra
revenir on essaie aussi d'être
partenaire de développement de
discipline et là on va aussi toucher le
problème des infrastructures je pense
notamment au football et la la D1
féminine auquel on croit beaucoup et
avec laquelle et on travaille
étroitement avec la Fédération pour son
développement là aussi très compliqué
pour certains clubs qui ont pas toujours
des stades adaptés qui doivent entre
guillemets demander l'homone un peu au
club masculin pour savoir s'il peut
jouer sur sa plouse qui en général
n'accepte pas
toujours et ça c'est c'est c'est c'est
dommage parce que moi je trouve qu'on
manque en France en fait de petits
stades mais modernes tu appelle petit
stade c'est 10 15000 places euh je pense
à un club comme juvizi euh qui est un
club phare de de de la D1 féminine et
qui malheureusement évolue au stade
Bondoufle qui est bon qui est quand même
qui a été fait presque dans un autre
siècle qui ressemble plus à un stade des
pays de l'Est qu'un qu'un qu'un stade
chaleureux même si elles s'y sentent
plutôt bien au moins pour y travailler
c'est quand même difficile pour nous
dansen dans dans d'en faire un spectacle
d'en faire un spectacle convivial euh
voilà donc c'est aussi de la natation
c'est c'est du cyclisme euh voilà donc
Eurosport se agit beaucoup là-dessus sur
toute la dimension populaire du sport en
essayant aussi de faire monter des
disciplines nous on est un peu comme un
club de football qui a pas forcément les
moyens de se payer Ibrahimovic donc on
doit avoir un centre de formation un
centre de développement des disciplines
de demain qui seront créatrices de
valeur donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
impliqué dans le sport féminin dans le
football féminin c'est pour ça qu'on a
été aussi les premiers à montrer du
biathlon en direct à la télévision donc
maintenant Martin Fourcade est un héros
national et tant mieux il le mérite mais
voilà tous les sports divers c'est toute
c'est toute l'année sur sur
Eurosport d'autres exemples aussi sur le
rugby où on éé premier à montrer des
matchs de fedéralune donc voilà on
essaie vraiment d'être ancré presque
dans l'aménagement du territoire du du
sport français et à ce titre j'aurais
pas mal d'anecdotes et d'exemples à vous
donner sur ce qu'on peut vivre au
quotidien à la fois dans les grand stade
mais aussi dans les dans les
petits merci donc pour terer ce premier
tour de table donc monsieur Vincent
chudel expert sport du cabinet C
salmont
bonjour Merci à vous monsieur le
Président merci à vous messieurs les
sénateurs de m'inviter à cette table
ronde je
suis atypique à cette table puisque je
ne suis pas moi-même représentant d'un
média pour autant et là je j'ai retrouvé
une une publication de sporté en 2010
dans laquelle je j'avais publié un une
tribune sur sport et média une relation
interdépendante construite en cinq
mouvements majeurs il avait les 5 temps
qui me semble intéressant de voir je
trouve que l'initiative de la mission
d'information est très
intéressante la
problématique qui ou les questions qui
ont été posées par écrit nous nous ont
amené à à réfléchir un peu en amont et
les premiers éléments que je me suis
noté moi c'est que c'est c'est un
problème complexe où il faut faire
attention aux fausses bonnes
idées ce
que chacun a dit précédemment finalement
c'est de dire que en plus des
droits télévisuel il y a des des coûts à
rajouter et donc en fait si on veut que
les médias accompagnent le sport d'une
façon générale il faut aussi qu'ils
puissent y retrouver leur compte et donc
avoir leur retour sur investissement
c'est un peu peu le côté consultant qui
qui prend le dessus dans mon propos mais
ça veut dire que pour que vous puissiez
chacun d'entre vous faire votre métier
comme bon vous semble le sujet porte sur
le contenu et le contenant aujourd'hui
tout ce crispe autour du contenant
c'estàd les infrastructures
effectivement pendant 50 ans on a eu
très peu d' de renouvellement de nos
infrastructures de de grands stades
construits et donc au niveau des
collectivités il y avait un
accompagnement de la performance un peu
plus de subvention quand l'équipe
montait un peu moins quand elle
descendait mais aujourd'hui le parc
d'une façon générale des stades des
salles est arrivé en en fin de vie et en
tout cas si le béton ne s'effrite pas en
fin de vie d'un point de vue des normes
télévisuelles pour travailler donc se
pose la question aujourd'hui de du
renouvellement des infrastructures et ça
ce sont des investissements terriblement
important et comme vous l'avez souligné
dans votre propos préliminaire euh c'est
bien souvent les collectivités
territoriales qui en assument le le le
la charge alors il y a des
mécanismes public privé mais le privé
lui aussi va chercher à identifier son
retour son investissement et euh on a
évoqué le sujet rapidement du du naming
mais même sur le PPP et le le cas de du
M le malheureux cas du M montre que le
mécanisme est encore jeune et est pas
encore consolidé bah l'aléa sportif qui
est la la base de l'activité ou du moins
de de du frisson que que cette activité
génère euh a du mal à cohabiter avec les
l'importance des des
investissements au niveau du contenu euh
je pense qu'il faut faire une
distinction entre sport individuel et
sport collectif où là il peut peut y
avoir des choses à faire et et à
organiser mais le sport individuel bien
on va se poser la question euh de bah
tout simplement de de notre capacité à
générer du talent en France
euh je travaille actuellement sur une
étude par rapport au 2.0 on a eu
énormément de mal à identifier des
sportives euh qui avaient une vraie
dynamique sur Twitter et sur Facebook on
a malheureusement et je pense qu'on on a
pu le constater euh pendant cette
quinzaine de de de jeux olympiques on a
probablement un trou générationnel euh
chez les filles aujourd'hui et quand on
est sur le sujet de du sujet du sport
féminin effectivement il y a des il y a
des disparités effectivement il y a un
vrai sujet mais il y a aussi un sujet de
formation et de talent euh quand vous
avez une Amélie morismo capable de
gagner un tournoi du grand schlem c'est
quand même plus facile de d'exposer du
tennis féminin que quand vous avez pas
une joueuse dans le top 10 mondial donc
faut distinguer la problématique des
sports individuels je pense des sports
collectifs où là il y a il y a des
choses àire faire dans les autres
éléments que que je me suis noté donc
euh pour revenir aussi sur les fausses
bonnes idées
euh par exemple exposer du du football
féminin euh c'est bien l'exposer par
exemple obligatoirement au au Parc des
Princes devant 5000 spectateurs ça
serait pas nécessairrement servir le
football féminin donc il va falloir
trouver aussi des Écrins j'en veux pour
preuve ce que le football le soccer a
réussi aux États-Unis au départ il
mettait les équipes de foot dans des
stades de foot US et faire 15 20000 dans
un stade de 80000 ça ça leur rendait pas
service ils ont décidé d'investir dans
des stades à taille pertinent et c'est
ce qui é évoqué là faire 15000 dans un
stade de 17 ou 18000 c'est pas du tout
la même chose que d'avoir 15000
spectateurs dans un stade de 50000 donc
voilà ça c'était pour le point de
attention au fausse fausse bonnes idées
ou fausses bonnes intentions euh je vous
ai parlé du contenu contenant moi ce qui
me semble important c'est effectivement
regardez qu'en 50 ans le secteur a
évolué énormément aujourd'hui on est
passé d'une dépendance à l'argent public
où on avait des clubs professionnels qui
dépendaient essentiellement de Monsieur
le maire et de ses subventions je parle
dans de secteur d'activité jusqu dans
les années 0 où on est passé à une
télédépendance euh et donc le réflex
serait de dire finalement il suffit
d'agir sur les médias pour régler bien
des sujets et je pense que ça va au-delà
de cela il y a donc une nécessité de
réinvestir les les les équipements et
donc au niveau des collectivités
probablement de faire des arbitrages et
là il y a un changement de culture et de
philosophie puisque jusqu'ici vous
pouviez accompagner tous les sports et
dans certains cas il faut faire
désormais des choix euh et et ça ce
n'est pas nécessement facile euh enfin
c'est pas facile c'est sûr et puis euh
une question et je reprends la casquette
sport et cyenté qui me semble importante
si on est au sujet au niveau des des des
sports collectifs c'est la fonction ou
le rôle social d'un club à quoi sert un
club et et je pense que et en France qu
on parlait tout à l'heure de des aspects
culturels par rapport aux anglo-saxons
et quand je dis anglo-saxons je pense
pas qu'aux
anglais il y a et probablement issu de
notre histoire un décalage entre la la
France et et nos voisins sur l'ancrage
populaire et l'attachement des des clubs
probablement parce qu'on a eu une
culture centralisatrice et que d'une
façon générale on préfère avoir un club
dans chaque sport dans dans dans chaque
ville alors que si on regarde nos
voisins vous avez parlé de Munich il a
Munich 1860 il y a le Bayern on peut
parler en Angleterre dans beaucoup de
villes vous avez toujours 1 2 3 enfin de
trois ou quatre clubs qui vont
représenter des catégorie de la
population et donc c'est le club de
votre père de votre arrière grand-père
de et et de vos ailleur et donc vous
avez un attachement bien plus important
donc il peut y avoir ce lien et en
France on l'a pas assez à mon avis et ça
c'est une question d'histoire et puis il
y a un rôle social du club et le rôle
social du club c'est aussi animer la
cité c'est-à-dire que
euh une ville pour être attractive elle
a besoin de d'activité économique
évidemment d'une activité académique de
la santé de la sécurité mais aussi d'une
activité culturelle si vous êtes dans
une ville qui veut avoir un rayonnement
européen et qui n'a pas d'aéroport c'est
un sujet sensible actuellement mais qui
n'a pas de théâtre qui n'a pas de
d'opéra et qui n'a pas de grands club de
foot vous serez probablement pas une
grande ville d'Europe donc ça ça fait
partie de de des sujets pour animer
votre population l'attirer euh il y a
des exemples très intéressants ce qu'a
fait Montpellier en en en 15 20 ans et
et et assez particulier et à souligner à
ce niveau-là et puis par rapport à ça et
j'en j'en j'en terminerai
euh donc le un des vrais sujets dans le
rôle social c'est aussi les les clés de
répartition et je pense que ça sera un
des sujets qui sera abordé entre une une
culture horizontale et une culture
verticale et je m'explique par euh
vertical c'està-dire est-ce que on doit
à tout prix considérer l'échelon 1 et
l'échelon 2 l'échelon 3 des compétitions
de la même façon où est-ce qu'il doit y
avoir des mécanismes de solidarité où
est-ce qu'on on estime que la fonction
d'un niveau 1 et d'un niveau 2 d'une
compétition n'est pas la
même d'une façon générale et c'est
naturel on a un intérêt économique tous
autant qu'on est pour l'échelon 1 d'une
compétition je ne sais pas si vous aimez
peu importe le le sport mais prenons par
exemple le sport
automobile ça n'a pas de sens de vouloir
diffuser
à à périmètrre comparable la le GP2 que
le le la Formule 1 parce que tout le
monde veut voir de la Formule 1 et GP2
on on rentre déjà dans un intérêt plus
plus centré et bien quels que soient les
moyens que vous mettrez dans une deuxème
division quel que soit le sport
l'intérêt G général de de la population
se centrera sur le niveau 1 l'intérêt
sur le niveau 2 sera essentiellement
local c'est là où vous avez le rôle
d'animation de la cité ou le rôle de
développement de et les Américains
appellent ça des ligues de développement
où vous mettez vous donner du temps de
jeu à des jeunes joueurs pour se
développer et il peut être intéressant
d'imaginer des mécanismes non pas des
mécanismes de solidarité non pas
financiers mais de de talent peut-être
donner du temps de jeu et à des à des
jeunes joueurs alors en 2e division plus
tôt que de que donner de l'argent alors
ça on va au-delà de des prérogatives des
médias puisque les les médias n'ont pas
la voix au chapitre à ce niveau-là c'est
plutôt des sujets de gouvernance donc là
où ça me semble intéressant ce débat
avec les avec le Sénat c'est que vous
êtes des acteurs du cadre législatif et
avoir une réflexion autour de des sports
et de leur développement oui ça impque
ça implique les les les les les médias
ça implique les collectivités ça
implique les les réflexions autour de la
gouvernance du
sport merci beaucoup donc je vais tout
de suite passer la parole à Stéphane
Mazar notre rapporteur qui
euh va vous poser des premières
questions merci monsieur le
Président merci à vous tous d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation je vous prie
de bien vouloir excuser mon retard vous
comprendrez que l'élu du département de
laavon que je suis se devait de passer
au salon de l'agriculture voilà donc
désolé pour ces quelques minutes de de
retard
euh je je commencerai par par vous poser
une question sur sur cette culture du
sport puisque j'ai cru comprendre que
Monsieur Bilalian dans votre propos vous
avez dit que peut-être on nétait pas
aujourd'hui à la même à la même je et à
la même hauteur que que ce qui se
passait en Angleterre ou en Allemagne et
c'est vrai que nous nous sommes déplacés
dans ces pays nous avons visité les
infrastructures sportives qui a
accueille grand nombre de spectateurs
qui les accueille sur une période qui va
bien au-delà du simple fait de jeu du du
simple match donc il y a une véritable
culture dans ces pays de l'appropriation
du lieu où se pratique la discipline et
euh et en attachement comme vous l'avez
dit donc au club et et souvent ça
remonte à à plusieurs générations
euh aujourd'hui n nos interlocuteurs
nous disent
mais c'est le manque d'infrastructure
dans les sports de salle ou dans les
sport en plein aire euh qui justement ne
permet pas euh de s'approprier ce lieu
de sport ce lieu de pratique et qui ne
permet pas de cultiver euh cet
attachement entre les spectateurs et et
leur club euh voilà donc moi je vous je
vous livre cette réflexion euh parce que
derrière euh il y a effectivement une
poussée très forte pour l'appropriation
par les clubs sportifs de
l'infrastructure sportive soit en pleine
propriété ou soit par une jouissance euh
relativement importante et on a par
exemple dans le football le cas de Lyon
qui va qui va donc construire son propre
stade et nous avons l'exemple de la
Fédération Française de Rugby qui a
également un projet de stade propriété
de de la fédération et aujourd'hui nous
disent que que ces projets sont viables
parce qu'il va y avoir demain un
engoument des spectateurs euh à Lyon la
Fédération française de rugby avec le le
le le potentiel de spectateurs qui peut
se déplacer sur les matchs
internationaux et c'est vrai que parfois
nous sommes un peu dubitatif parce que
les exemples qu'on nous prend en
Allemagne ou en Angleterre effectivement
ils répondent encore une fois à ces
cultures qui qui nous sont bien
différentes alors voilà est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut d'abord faire
l'infrastructure et ensuite on arrivera
à créer ce lien et cet engouement autour
de l'événement sportif euh ou est-ce que
ça vous semble encore un petit peu
illusoire qui souhaite prendre la parole
en
premier vous avez tous r essayer de
répondre non je pense je pense si si
j'ai évoqué ça tout à l'heure dans mon
propos préliminaire c'est que je pense
que
naturellement notre pays n'est pas un
pays sportif au sens où l' entend les
anglo-saxons et et et les Allemands ou
les Américains d'abord parce que
j'allais dire que nous n'avons pas de
sport scolaire véritablement il y a pas
d'équipe d'école en France il y a pas de
sport avant l'université et encore alors
qu'aux États-Unis vous avez un
championnat universitaire de basket qui
est presque du niveau de la NBA donc il
y a pas de culture du sport à l'école
moi je suis une génération de de
l'après-guerre nous faisions la
gymnastique en costume pour ne pas
perdre de temps et ne pas faire attendre
le prof de mat donc on sautait quand
même en hauteur en costume et en cravate
B ça c'est un peu amélioré je je suppose
mais je ne pense pas que dans les lycées
français le sport soit mis en avant donc
ça commence là donc pour faire du sport
en France on ne peut pas le faire à
l'école faut aller déjà dans un club
donc il faut avoir faut faire une
démarche sportive de la famille alors
que en
Angleterre les stades sont là les
enfants peuvent aller jouer au football
en France il y a quoi il y a un terrain
de hand parce qu'il y a un petit hall
dans lequel on peut jouer au hand avec
un panier de basket peut-être pour ça
par ailleurs que la suite les Français
n'aiment plus le basket autant que
autant que le football ou nime plus aant
le handball parce qu'ils en tropit à
l'école dans de mauvaises
conditions non je pense que véralement
ça alors créer créer créer le besoin en
créant un bel endroit pour pratiquer le
sport ça quelque chose quand même
d'artificiel évidemment on pense tous
aux après-midis autour du stade de
twikenam ou dès le matin ou bien Arsenal
ou dès le matin les les supporters sont
là on discute et après on reste c'est
dans le stade moi je vous conseille pas
tellement de rester autour du stade de
France si vous tenez à votre carte bleue
voilà c'est tout hein euh donc on n pas
d'endroit les endroits que nous créons
ne sont pas luni et en plus il est très
important en Grande-Bretagne c'est de
créer des stades qui soit dans la ville
si vous êtes à Londres les stades sont
en ville en France on a le Parc des
Princes est en ville c'est très
important quand le stade est éloigné de
la ville comme était le projet de stade
de France avant qu'il ne soit mis à
Saint-Denis c'est
terrifiant et Roland Garos s'éloignant
de la capitale parce qu'on peut pas
couper un arbre en face du du bois de
Boulogne effectivement c'est c'est c'est
dramatique c'est dramatique parce que
vous vous repoussez le le spectateur qui
n'est déjà pas très je pense que le le
sport intramuros fait par partie de la
ville fait partie de la ville si vous
allez à
Londres vous j'ai vécu moi en Angleterre
les stades sont dans la ville qu'il soit
alors alors à contrario vous allez vous
allez à twikenam oublodon c'est au bout
du monde mais je pense que viscéralement
je reviens toujours je pense que créer
artificiellement un stade et dire que
c'est c'est le stade qui va créer une
atmosphère sportive dans la ville un
engoulement un attachement je pense que
un c'est faux de les performances sont
quand même essentielles les performances
sont essentielles en France les
performances sont essentielles c'est pas
vrai en Grande-Bretagne euh en
Grande-Bretagne le type restera attaché
à son club même s'il est descendu en 3e
ou en 4e division c'est son club c'est
son club c'est là il il vit il en parle
toute la semaine au bar au pub et cetera
nous la désertification des stades
regardez l'histoire du M l'histoire du M
elle est terrible le M se construit un
stade voilà qui devrait être normalement
l'exemple le même de ce qu' doit se
faire il trouvve une société privée les
assurances sont installées à
moment on construit un stade sur des
fonds privés et le club descend en 2è
division il y a plus personne et
aujourd'hui ils sont en cessation de
paiement c'est terrifiant ça veut dire
qu'il y a rien alors que en
Grande-Bretagne les gens continueront à
aller voir pormous même s'ils sont en 3e
division même s'ils sont en 3è division
parce que c'est la sortie c'est la
sortie c'est la sortie alors c'est
peut-être aussi une des particularités
de notre de des Français de notre peuple
de s'intéresser à beaucoup de choses et
pas simplement au sport parce que
remarquez que les pays où ça fonctionne
très très bien c'est des pays où
l'aspect de la vie culturelle est
extrêmement limité que vous soyez aux
États-Unis ou en Grande-Bretagne il y a
pas il y a pas la bonne bouffe avec la
bellemer ou au restaurant il y a pas la
notion de sortie et cetera non nous on a
une vie culturelle le français moyen a
une vie culturelle beaucoup plus intense
que nos que nos voisins britannique par
exemple qui qui qui se tourne donc tout
ça ce sont des choses très anciennes qui
comme ça semblent mais elles sont elles
sont elles sont réelles elles sont
réelles un anglais n'hésitera pas
entreer aller manger che sa belle-mère
le samedi et aller au
stade ça je vous en fiche mon billet
hein et passer même la journée autour du
stade et c'est pas vrai chez nous donc
ça crée ça alors si le club est
performant on y va ensuite il y a une
chose très importante c'est le prix
aussi prix des
places c'est c'est quelque chose qui qui
qui qui pèse sur un budget familial le
prix des places alors il y a eu aussi
dans certains club les problèmes de
sécurité mais bon c'est pas ça
l'essentiel le prix le prix peut être
négatif dans des familles si vous voulez
emmener vos enfants ça ça représentent
des sommes qui sont relativement
considérables donc moi je pense
que la construction d'un d'un stade
c'est quelque chose d'un d'un stade d'un
beau stade parce que les diffuseurs ne
sont pas exigeants au sens strict du
terme mais par exemple pour les sur une
chaîne thématique un passionné va
pouvoir regarder un match dans un stade
vide euh parce que le club a été
sanctionné parce qu'il y a personne
parce qu'il s'intéresse à ce sport mais
je peux vous dire que sur TF1 ou chez
nous stade plein égal événement stade
vide égale non événement même si si vous
faites France Brésil 98 dans un stade
vide c'est pas le même résultat que
France- Brésil avec 80000
spectateurs nous c'est très important
nous parce qu'aujourd'hui avec la avec
la division c'était pas le cas
auparavant mais avec l'arrivée des
chaînes thématiques les chaînes
événementielles comme TF1 ous dit
historique nous n'avons jamais diffusé
de championnat que ce soit de football
ou de rugby parce qu'il y a trois matchs
par qui ferait du public hein euh en
revanche avec l'arrivée des chaînes
thématiques aujourd'hui le le le système
est simple donc récurrent événement
récurrents chaîne thématique et nous les
gens ne viennent plus voir chez nous que
des événements de sport ils viennent
plus voir de sport pour vous donner un
exemple nous le le canal plus diffuse le
Top 14 de rugby et nous codiffusons la
finale et bien les gens viennent voir la
finale chez nous parce que c'est une
fête parce que c'est un événement c'est
très curieux mais c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça ça alors qu'il devrait
normalement rester sur Canal Plus qui
sont les meilleurs d'ailleurs ils le
disent eux-mêmes il y a aucune raison de
les contrarier
euh sont des gens qui ne se détestent
pas bref
euh c'est dommage qu' soit pas là
j'aurais dit la même chose mais ça nous
empêche pas de travailler avec eux donc
je pense que faire un une relation
directe entre qualité des inv des
investissements qualité des stades et
engouement du public c'est c'est une
erreur fondamentale et alors ce qu' a
fait remarquer Florent tout à l'heure
c'est vrai c'est sur la construction des
stades par exemple pourquoi est-ce que
le le pourquoi est-ce que le football
britannique est mieux filmé que le nôtre
c'est que dans les dans les stades en
Grande-Bretagne les caméras sont placées
moins plus bas plus bas mais ça supprime
des
places mais si vous voulez si regardez
bien la différence entre un match filmé
en Grande-Bretagne et chez nous nous les
stades les les les caméras son en haut
comme ça ça fait 50 places de plus et on
vous fouile sous les toits et alors que
en Grande-Bretagne dans les angles et
sur sur sur les sur les tribunes les
caméras sont à mis hauteur mais ell
bouchent la vue de X nombre de
spectateurs qui auraient pu prendre
place mais vous avez une qualité de
retransmission qui est 10 fois
supérieure je parle s sous le contrôle
de mes amis à la nôtre et donc le stade
de Lille personne n'a
demandé bon je pense que c gens qui
avaient la science infuse donc il avait
aucune raison de demander quoi que ce
soit mais voilà c'est c'est une erreur
fondamentale et voilà un stade qui qui
n'est pas adapté alors qu'il est tout
qu'il est qu'il est flambant neuf
voilà il y a peut-être aussi une une
question pardon il y a peut-être aussi
une question fondamentale sur alors
c'est peut-être de la provocation mais
est-ce que la fédération de rugby
aujourd'hui a vraiment un intérêt à
construire son stade pour combien de
matchs par an c'est 3 qu matchs du
tournoi c'est 3 qu test match dans
l'année c'est c'est 10
matchs voilà donc qui est responsable
c'est ce que je disais tout tout à
l'heure c'est je pense que le problème
il faut le prendre au départ on a des
projets chacun veut son stade même dans
des grandes agglomérations comme la
région parisienne puisqu'on est dans la
région parisienne il y a beaucoup de
stades mais il y a pas de salle
omnisport là on va se lancer peut-être
dans la fédération de rugby un projet de
construire un nouveau stade voilà donc
je pense qu'il faut peut-être avoir une
réflexion au départ de se dire dans une
région il y a tel ou tel club peut-être
même au sein de club d'organiser une une
volonté de de pôle omnisport et d'avoir
au sein du même club une division hand
une division basket une division volée
évidemment une division football mais à
travers la la division volée basket ou
handball pouvoir peut-être
mutualiser une une une structure qui du
coup ne servirait pas que 10 fois par an
mais 30 ou 40 fois du coup là en plus on
s'approprie encore plus vite l'enceinte
voilà je pense qu'il y a cette réflexion
et déjà peut-être éviter une nouvelle
fois avec de tels projets alors là on
parle du rugby mais peut-être qu'un jour
qu' une autre fédération ou un autre
club aura aussi un projet de construire
un stade pour combien de matchs
oui pour pour compléter ce qui ce qui a
été
dit on a pu faire de de nombreuses
études économiques sur le sujet et on a
pu démontrer que le spectateur est
l'élément moteur du business model du
sport spectacle du sport
professionnel donc et ça confirme ce qui
ce qui a été dit précédemment
c'està-dire si si vous allumez votre
votre télé vous avez un record du monde
devant un stade vide rappelons-nous le
record du monde du 100 m qui avait été
fait à charletti
devant je sais pas moi charletti c'est
tout le temps 10 personnes donc c'est
pas difficile de il y en avait peut-être
30 quand même ce jourl ben c'est pas un
record du monde c'est évidemment
sportivement un record du monde mais on
c'est pas le même frisson c'est pas la
même émotion
donc même si le spectateur la
billetterie ne représente pas l'élément
majeur du du business model c'est
l'élément qui génère la création de
valeur pour les sponsors pour les
annonceurs pour les partenaires pour les
diffuseurs donc ça c'est un point très
important et effectivement on a pu d'une
façon générale dé monrer que quand il y
avait une infrastructure nouvelle on
pouvait
avoir une demande al c'est le sujet de
de l'offre et de la demande du poule de
de la poule et de l'œuf mais en général
un équipement nouveau génère une
consommation plus importante pour autant
et je reviens sur le sujet de la culture
en France elle n'est pas assez enracinée
qui fait que quand Leem lance son
nouveau stade il a une meilleure
affluence qu'il n'aurait eu au même
niveau de la compétition avant mais si
la performance chute c'est sil y a
relégation bah c'est pas assez consolidé
et ça
s'écroule une fois qu'on a dit ça le
problème c'est que un stade ça se
construit pas pour les 5 prochaines
années il faut imaginer le stade de
demain et et aujourd'hui mes euh je peux
pas dire confrères mais mes amis à la
table
euh
ont une question qui va se poser à eux
qui se pose probablement déjà à eux mais
beaucoup moins aujourd'hui que demain
c'est qu'est-ce que je vais pouvoir
proposer au téléspectateurs pour qu'il
ait envie de suivre ce match non pas
physiquement dans le stade mais à
l'écran et la problématique que
rencontrent les clubs et les ligues
c'est quce ce qui fait que je vais
arracher la personne de son fauteuil
pour l'emmener dans mon stade et pas euh
rester devant euh dans dans son salon à
regarder les très belles images parce
queelles sont très bien produites euh
ils sont au chaud ils peuvent manger ce
qu'ils veulent ils peuvent recevoir leur
belle- mère si la belle- mère est là et
cetera et cetera qu'est-ce qui fait que
je vais prendre en plein hiver ma
voiture y aller avec mes amis et mes
enfants voilà c'est euh les deux
questions que chacun se pose d'un côté
ou de l'autre et la réalité des choses
c'est quand vous êtes chez vous vous
pouvez revoir 12 fois le ralenti vous
avez une tonne de statistiques et cetera
et donc il y a toutes les problématiques
du stade connecté qui doit
permettre à l'individu au citoyens que
vous êtes et je suis d'avoir une
expérience soit dans le stade soit dans
mon salon dans le salon ça vous concerne
ami diffuseur dans le stade ça vous
concerne
amis collectivité territorial qui vont
participer bien souvent
à l'investissement mais il faut pas
opposer l'un et l'autre il faut dans les
deux cas penser à l'intérêt du
consommateur final et dans les deux cas
lui permettre de de développer des
solutions du
coup il ne faut pas nécessairement aller
dans des stades toujours plus grands
mais ce qui est clair c'est qu'il faut
renouveler l'infrastructure des stades
ou des
Arenas l'approche connectée elle est à
intégrer dans la réflexion d'aujourd'hui
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
quasiment obligé de réfléchir à des
nouvelles infrastructures qui sont
évidemment bien plus coûteuses que
qu'hier où on avait finalement à
construire des tribunes et un toit un
bloc de vestiaire et là c'est des
problématiques un peu plus un peu plus
larges c'était pour répondre à votre
question de est-ce que la clé est au
niveau de l'infrastructure je pense que
c'est un préalable mais évidemment que
ça ne suffit pas mais c'est un
préalable d'accord
euh oui plusieurs choses par rapport à
tout
ça je pense que il y a une notion de
confort quand même qui est extrêmement
importante quand on va au stade notion
de confort et de famille aussi euh je
pense qu'on arrivera à remplir plus de
stade si on y est mieux effectivement il
faut la il faut toute la les la
connectique nécessaire parce que quand
on est au stade on a envie de tweeter
qu'on est au stade si on peut pas
tweeter qu'on est au stade ben on Râ
c'estàd qu'on a pas les mêmes les mêmes
possibilités de de d'échang que ce qu'on
que ce qu'on peut avoir chez soi il faut
que ce soit pas trop loin je pense qu'il
faut arrêter de penser que les gens vont
faire 3/4 d'heure 1 heure 1 heure et/art
de transport en commun 1 heure de
voiture pour aller dans un parking qui
qui qui est à 2 km moi ça je'y crois
absolument pas et c'est vrai que le
stade de rugby quand on me dit qu'il
sera au cœur de les sones c'est
peut-être un endroit magnifique c'est
loin ça va être compliqué pour pour que
les gens aillent là-bas il faut que ce
soit facile il faut que ce soit
accessible il faut que ce soit
confortable il faut qu'il y ait des
stades qui soit je suis d'accord avec
Daniel au cœur des cités qui qui est
tout un complexe autour aussi souvent on
fait le stade et puis finalement ça
s'arrête là il faut des des cinémas
intégré pour que éventuellement la
petite sœur la grande sœur ou la maman
ou la belle-mère puisque c'est la
l'héroïne cet après-midi puisse aussi
pendant ce temps-là peut-être aller
aller voir un film ou aller faire aller
faire du shopping parce qu'il y a un
centre commercial un mole qui est pas
loin c'est c'est ce qu'on on fait aussi
les les Américains ça je pense qu'on est
capable de l'imaginer euh je trouve que
ce qui est intéressant aussi dans la
démarche de Lyon avec le stade des
lumière a-delà de de cette particularité
de posséder son stade mais on voit bien
la difficulté quand même bon là ça se
passe mieux en deuxième partie de saison
qu'à qu'à Jean-Michel olas d'arriver à
une équipe qui puisse continuer à se
maintenir à peu près à un certain niveau
jusqu'à l'arrivée du stade et des
revenus supplémentaires qui lui
permettront peut-être de jouer un peu
plus les les haut tableau et pourquoi
pas la la Ligue des des champions c'est
cette démarche qui qui de dire comment
faire venir la famille et en fait dans
toute cette cette vision qu' eu qu' a eu
olas quand Mme même sur le le le
football féminin par rapport au public
féminin qui vient à gerl quand il y a
des matchs qui est pas le même que le
public masculin qui est pas le même
c'est petit à petit amener ce public à
être captif à l'accompagner pour qu'il
viennent aussi le jour où l'OL sera au
stade des Lumières dans des conditions
meilleures que toute la famille qui
vientn voir les matchs de l'OL féminin
bien peut-être aussi viennent voir les
matchs de l'OL masculin ce qui a créé
vraiment un univers OL global et j'ai
trouvé cette cette démarche extrêmement
intéressante mais je pense que il faut
pas oublier que on vit tous voilà on est
quand même dans une société de confort
on veut être bien on veut être bien
assis la démarche je trouve aussi qu' le
qu' le PSG est assez assez innovante sur
savoir où est-ce que je vais être placé
pourquoi pas commander à l'avance mon
hot dog ou ma bière enfin quand on veut
une bière au Stade de France qui
d'ailleurs même pas une bière mais le
prix c'est c'est juste hallucinant je
sais pas si vous avez vu quel est le le
prix d'une bière au Stade de France je
veux pas dire de bêtises mais c'est
quelque chose comme 10 € une tourtelle
quoi
donc on a beau être hein pas de marque
pardon non mais c'est même pas une
tourtelle donc c'est et quand vous êtes
à plusieurs et vouz prendre une bière ou
les hotdog pour les enfants c'est quand
même compliqué donc il faut faciliter la
vie faciliter
l'accès et vraiment considérer regardez
ce qui s'est passé pour le cinéma les
multiplex quelque part c'est peut-être
ce qui a sauvé le cinéma en France dans
les 20 ou 25 dernières années c'estàd on
avait des stades des pardon des salles
qui étaient partout pas toujours équipé
des petits écrans et PU puis il y a eu
cette volonté de faire des des lieux de
vie en fait quelque part où on vient on
peut on peut on peut y dîner casser la
croûte pourquoi pas se faire de film les
enfants on peut tranquillement il
peuvent tranquillement aller voir un
film qui leur plaît on les récupère
après à la fin de la séance et puis les
parents vont voir autre chose je pense
qu'il faut vraiment concevoir ça comme
des lieux de vie des lieux de confort
des lieux de spectacles avec des
multiactivités et et dans dans ce cadre
là je pense qu'il y a il y a possibilité
de remplir beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
cestard en France et je le redis pas que
du gigantisme des stades aussi de 10000
12000 13000 places
mais mais qui qui ont toutes les
qualités d'accueil nécessaire et et par
exemple aussi sur le le football féminin
aura besoin dans l'avenir de de ce de ce
type de stade parce que je suis d'accord
aller mettre faire jouer le PSG féminin
au parc devant 5000 ou 6000 ou 7000
personnes ben ça ça ça ça donnera
rien non je pense que tout ce qui ce qui
est dit est assez juste maintenant je
pense qu'il faut pas non plus
cristalliser les choses autour d'un
d'une clé d'entrée le stade les droits
télé je pense qu'aujourd'hui on parle de
club
professionnel on parle donc d'un
spectacle ce sont des entreprises de
spectacle finalement ces ces clubs
professionnels donc ils sont là pour
attirer du monde mais ils sont là aussi
pour développer un modèle économique qui
fonctionne donc je pense que le la prère
question et en Angleterre c'est vrai que
les stades sont plein en 3e en 4e
division en Allemagne il y a 45000
personnes de moyenne dans les stades de
de D1 c'est pas le cas en France mais
peut-être que ça ne le sera jamais
peut-être que c'est en effet culturel et
peut-être qu'on est pas très sportif et
que ça nous intéresse pas plus que ça ou
alors quand la France se qualifie contre
l'Ukraine au Stade de France mais je
pense surtout qu'il faut réfléchir un
modèle économique qui intègre l'ensemble
des paramètres qui permettent à un club
profession n de vivre sainement
économiquement c'est de la billetterie
donc en effet du stade
des des stades confortables qui
permettent aussi de vendre de la
tourtelle ou des saucisses pour pouvoir
faire quelques rentrées financières
supplémentaires mais c'est aussi du
marketing c'est du sponsoring ce sont
des droits télé mais je pense que c'est
un bon équilibre entre l'ensemble de ces
paramètres économiques qui permettent
justement de trouver la bonne cible en
terme de stade en terme d'infrastructure
et en terme de modèle économique général
en Angleterre les stad sont pleins mais
ils ont développé le marketing ils ont
développé le merchandising ils ont
développé le sponsoring ils ont
développé les droits téléinnational et
je pense qu'à un moment il faut aussi
tenir compte de l'ensemble de ces
paramètres et pas seulement essayer de
prendre le plus d'argent possible aux
chaînes de télé euh pour après
l'utiliser comme il le souhaite euh
essayer de faire le plus grand stade
possible pour avoir finalement des
remplissages assez faibles je pense
qu'il faut mettre à plat l'ensemble de
de ces paramètres pour avoir une
réflexion qui soit cohérente et qui soit
adaptée aussi au pays ou à la région
dans laquelle on est donc je pense qu'il
faut prendre ça comme une entreprise
professionnelle de spectacle c'est un
spectacle avant tout et nous à la télé
c'est un spectacle on offre un spectacle
à nos téléspectateurs ils viennent voir
un match qui leur fait plaisir bien sûr
que c'est mieux si le stade est plein
mais il faut que le match soit sympa
aussi si le match n'est pas intéressant
si la compétition n'est pas intéressante
personne viendra ni au stade ni devant
la télé donc tout ça n'est pas
d'ailleurs opposé tout ça se complète
bien peut-être que les stades doivent
être un peu plus connectés mais d'un
autre côté on remplira pas non plus 10
millions de personnes dans un stade donc
un stade 40000 personnes dans un stade
et 4 5 millions de téléspectateurs sur
un grand événement tout ça est
totalement compatible absolument pas
opposé tout ça doit fonctionner je
dirais dans un
dans un écosystème qui qui qui doit être
cohérent en fait il y a il y a il y a il
y a deux réflexion peut-être à faire
c'est que le dans le système de
financement des des clubs de football
par exemple ou même des clubs de rugby
sur des contrats avec la télévision qui
a emporté le marché sur 3 ou 4 ans il y
a un système très très très particulier
des des responsables du football et des
présidents du club c'est que et c'est
qui explique que le programme soit soit
pas toujours de la même qualité sauf
maintenant pour deux clubs qui n'ont pas
de problème d'argent que sont le
parissaggermain et Monaco la première
année en général après la signature d'un
bon contrat télévisé on achète des
joueurs la 2uxe année on les conserve la
3oè année on se dit est-ce que le
prochain contrat sera aussi bon donc on
commence à revendre des joueurs et la
dernière année on se contente de réparer
les quelques fuites qu'il y a dans le
toit de la tribune présidentielle donc
ça fait qu'on a un programme qui qui qui
qui commence très haut à chaque
signature et qui finit beaucoup plus bas
par ailleurs il y a un système qui il y
a un système qui permettrait de régler
ces problèmes et de faire vraiment du du
sport
professionnel j'allais dire une
entreprise économique viable sur
lesqueles les partenaires n'hésiteraient
pas à s'engager c'est c'est mais qui est
contraire à l'état d'esprit du sport
c'est la Ligue fermée les Américains
font ce système c'est-à-dire vous êtes
en première division sauf à faire une
faillite commerciale au sens strict du
terme vous avez votre licence vous avez
vous obtenez de rester donc
l'investissement il est de longue durée
pour les sponsors qui sont les vôtres
vous avez une zone de chalandise un peu
comme les pharmacies c'est on n pas le
droit d'installer le club à moins de
tant de kilomètres de chez vous donc
commercialement vous vendez des maillots
vous vendez du sponsoring sur une région
très importante ça c'est le système ça
c'est un vrai système économique il y a
pas de crainte il y a pas de phénomène
comme le phénomène du man à ce moment-là
les investisseurs il vont en se disant
sauf faillite commerciale on est là
ditam et ternam en fait le si on veut
vraiment professionnaliser le sport les
Américains le font très bien c'est ce
système là qu'il faut faire ce système
là il est sans aléa moi je suis un
investisseur je vais je vais je vais
réfléchir à deux fois avant d'investir
dans le football parce que j'investis à
Valencienne valencienne va descendre
j'investi à socho est-ce que socho va
pas descendre et cetera et cetera à
quelques exceptions près je ne suis
absolument pas sûr de mon placement donc
le système de la Ligue fermé dans un
monde où l'argent à l'époque où l'argent
ne régnait pas en mare céit pas grave
CIT pas grave du tout même c'était c'est
ce qui fait la beauté du sport mais dans
un système où pour construire un stade
il faut avoir des partenaires pour gérer
le stade il faut avoir des partenaires
pour faire rentrer de l'argent il faut
avoir des droits il faut percevoir des
droits télé est-ce que ce système qui
avait le mérite d'être j'allais dire
très coubertinesque est-ce qu'il a
encore une est-ce qu'il a encore une
valeur aujourd'hui est-ce que si on veut
que les stades se construisent est-ce
que si on veut que des investisseurs
mettent de la argent dans les clubs
est-ce que c'est pas ce système là qu'il
faut alors c'est autre chose le sport
devient un spectacle vous allez au
spectacle comme vous allez voir un
chanteur ou un balai vous n'allez plus
voir quelque chose qui qui qui vous
remue les tripes parce que vous dites il
mon club descend c'est quel donc vous
êtes dans un autre état d'esprit mais
est-ce que c'est pas l'état d'esprit de
notre époque et aujourd'hui vous voyez
bien que dans le football de première
division vous avez un club qui est une
sorte de ballyball choy et qui va faire
des tournées en province hein voilà
il risque rien je veux dire et il vous
il vous demande combien de buts vous
voulez prendre pour pas avoir l'air
ridicule pointer la ligne ve dire on en
est là ne nous racontons pas d'histoire
c'est les bal moissyev qui vont jouer à
Carcassonne quoi grosso modo et il y a
aucun risque alors est-ce que je pense
que c'est un problème générationnel pour
pour les gens des jeunes générations ça
n' sans doute pas d'importance mais
est-ce que pour autant c'est c'est
quelque chose qui qui soit très
sympathique je je ne suis pas certain je
pense que c'est ce que dit Daniel par
rapport au Paris Saint-Germain ou à
Monaco je pense qu'il faut pas voir non
plus l'arrivée d'investisseur parce que
tout ça est positif typiquement vous
avez effectivement deux club aujourd'hui
mais à l'époque c'était Lyon pendant 7
ans qui gagnait tous les championnats
aujourd'hui c'est parisaggermain c'est
Monaco mais grâce à l'arrivée de ces
investisseurs vous avez la valeur du
championnat qui a augmenté la valeur du
championnat à l'étranger par exemple les
droits télé à l'étranger ont été
multiplié par 3 ou par qu donc
indirectement c'est également de
l'argent qui revient aux différents
clubs dans la redistribution qui est
évidemment pas de la responsabilité des
diffuseurs mais qui est qui est de la
responsabilité des des des clubs des
ligues des fédérations mais le diffuseur
a aussi et les clubs ce que disait tout
à l'heure François sur la recherche de
revenus supplémentaire en France on a un
peu de mal à bousculer les habitudes je
vous donne un exemple aujourd'hui depuis
3 4 ans la Ligue de football la LFP a
imaginé et à essayer un peu d'avancer en
allant chercher des revenus addition des
revenus des droits télé à l'étranger
mais ça passe par quoi ça passe par des
cas horaires de match par exemple
dimanche à 14h qui n'était pas une
habitude en France aujourd'hui
régulièrement nous à BeIn Sport en
diffusant des matchs de Ligue 1 à 14h on
a des clubs qui des présidents des
entraîneurs qui on a l'impression de
leur demander de jouer à 8h le matin il
faut peut-être aussi regarder en Europe
typiquement en Espagne vous jouez tous
les dimanches à midi en Italie la série
a vous jouez aussi tous les dimanches à
m et demi et c'est pas les clubs du bas
de classement vous avez pas
régulièrement mais une fois ou deux fois
par mois soit le Barcelone ou soit le
Real de Madrid qui parfois peut être
amené à jouer le midi mais pourquoi
c'est pour le marché asiatique donc
c'est des revenus supplémentaires qui
évidemment reviennent nous en France on
est vraiment on a du mal à changer les
habitudes à bousculer les habitudes mais
on veut aussi avoir les mêmes les mêmes
avantages ou les mêmes revenus que
peuvent avoir les clubs étrangers donc
il faut évidemment regarder pourquoi les
clubs étrangers en Allemagne en
Angleterre fonctionnent mieux les stades
sont bien remplis parce qu'effectivement
peut-être que dans certaines régions de
faire 50 km de voiture pour aller au
stade c'est peut-être plus pratique de
le faire le dimanche à 14h ou le
dimanche à 17h que le dimanche à
21h donc c'est un peu tout ça qu'il faut
mais je pense qu'il y a aussi une une
recherche à la base de revenus
supplémentaires on peut pas non plus
attendre à chaque fois trop des
collectivités ou trop des des diffuseurs
il faut aussi comme le disait François
que les entreprises de de de football et
les clubs sont aujourd'hui des des des
entreprises de spectacle et à un moment
donné c'est des entreprises privées et
il faut peut-être aussi chacun a des
budgets à inspecter que ce soit les
pouvoirs publics que ce soit les
diffuseurs que ce soit les les
entreprises essayer de trouver des
solutions où elles sont mais il faut
aussi oser bousculer les les habitudes
et l'exemple du 14h c'est quelque chose
de de significatif parce que nous à bin
je peux vous dire que régulièrement euh
certains un club sont pas très contents
de jouer à 14h euh mais bon c'est c'est
pas les chaînes aussi qui fixent les
horaires de match souvent c'est souvent
les chaînes qui sont montrées du doigt
euh vous les diffuseurs vous nous
imposez tout à l'heure tout à l'heure
non les diffuseurs achètent un événement
à un certain prix avec certaines
obligations de production donc des coûts
supplémentaires des cases horaires et
ensuite c'est les les les les on va dire
les les diffuseurs et et les ligues en
l'occurrence qui font la programmation
des match mais c'est pas c'est toujours
le diffuseur qui est montré du du doigt
souvent lui le responsable faut de temps
en temps rappeler c'est ce qu'on fait
nous aussi au président de club en leur
disant il faut vous souvenir à l'époque
il y a 2 3 ans quand vous étiez autour
de la table du conseil d'administration
de la Ligue que c'est vous qui avez voté
cet appel d'offre ce découpage de match
dans un but d'augmenter les droits télé
ce que vous avez réussi à faire mais à
un moment donné il faut pas oublier non
plus les
conséquences
ah on a bien compris que vous étiez très
peu voire pas du tout associé donc en
amont des des des projet
d'infrastructure sportive stade ouou
grande
salle vous pouvez nous décrire les
principales exigences que que vousfin
que que que vous sollicitez enfin qui
qui sont les vôtres pour retransmettre
donc un spectacle sportif en matière de
de luxe des projecteurs d'emplacement de
de caméras pour qu'on puisse nous avoir
une idée de de ce que ça peut
représenter
et et ces exigences là donc pour la
retransmission de d'un spectacle sportif
comment vous les formalisez avec les
organisateurs des compétitions est-ce
que c'est par convention
euh est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
plus si vous permettez là-dessus je
voudrais rajouter dire dire quelque
chose d'abord sortir un peu du foot
euh avec un exemple puisque j'ai posé la
question aux équipes production
d'Eurosport qui sement quand même que
malgré tout il y a un effort de de
consultation supplémentaire qui est fait
avant la construction d'une enceinte
unee Arena ou d'un stade ça reste plus
ou moins appuyé on sait pas exactement
ce qu'il en ce qu'il en est derrière
mais quand même il y a il y a cette
prise en compte là là j'ai l'exemple que
je peux vous donner précis du consortium
de lî qui va pour la nouvelle piscine à
tourcoin où là on a été consulté parce
qu'on est partenaire de la Fédération
française de natation avec une liste
très précise éclairage des bassins conn
Wii réseau alimentation puissance pour
les car régies très souvent on est
obligé de rajouter des groupes
électrogènes parce que la puissance
électrique ne permet pas ou nous met
trop en risque par rapport à une
diffusion en direct il y a rien de pire
que se retrouver avec ça nous est arrivé
il y a pas très longtemps dans un stade
de province sur un un match de l'équipe
de France des U20 poum quoi ça disjoncte
donc c'est un petit peu gênant les
besoins en matière de câblage che mal
l'emplacement des des caméras donc il y
a cet exemple de de piscine que m'a
donné le le directeur production pour
dire voilà il y a quand même à un
certain moment des des vrais efforts de
consultation qui qui sont faits et ça
progresse sur
l'éclairage c'est un élément absolument
essentiel surtout quand on est passé en
HD parce que plus vous vous améliorz la
qualité de la captation plus vous avez
besoin d'un éclairage performant en
l'occurrence pour la HD il vous faut
1200 luxe pour faire vraiment le soir un
match en en qualité maximale qui vous
permet aussi d'utiliser des loupe plus
la caméra est précise et et et profonde
dans ce qu'elle doit montrer et plus il
y a de ralenti plus vous avez besoin
d'un éclairage optimal c'est très
souvent là où le Besse euh peut-être pas
dans les plus grands stades mais dès que
vous êtes en Ligue 2 ou en Coupe de
France vous vous retrouvez avec des 450
500 600 luxe euh c'est très très juste
et c'est dommage parce que parfois ça ça
empêche des retransmissions de de de de
villes petite ou moyenne Ben qui qui
aimeraient avoir la la possibilité
d'être en direct parce que c'est une
fête et elles accueillent un grand club
donc soit elles sont obligées de se
délocaliser dans un club qui n'est ou
dans un stade qui n'est pas le leure
soit du coup
elles le font quand même mais elles sont
pas
diffusées donc ça c'est c'est un point
aussi Qui est qui est fort dommage voilà
voilà typiquement des exigences de
qualité de captation audiovisuelle qui
ont augmenté avec la HD des luxes
supplémentaires et puis benah la plupart
des stades qui ont pas qui ont pas pu
suivre qui n'ont pas qui n'ont pas
intégré toujours cet élément là c'est
évidemment pas le cas pour la pour la
Ligue 1 mais c'est le cas pour pour
beaucoup d'autres stades voilà ce que je
pourrais ajouter làdessus je voudrais
juste donner un exemple
aussi et ce sera intéressant peut-être à
l'occasion de certains de consultations
l'exemple du Grand prix moto au donc
piloté par clon michi qui d'ailleurs
aussi président d'un club de Ligue 2 le
club de Clermont qui a repris un grand
prix qui était d'abord qui n'existait
plus en France et qui en a fait un des
grand pris dans au sens large du terme
de roues quatre roues les plus
populaires et en terme
de de nombre de spectateurs qui qui
viennent sur ce sur ce Grand Prix je
crois que c'est je pas dire de bêtises
mais ça quelque chose comme 150000
personnes ou même plus qui viennent sur
2 TR jours et là toute la créativité
qu'il a fallu pour en faire un événement
pour créer des animations autour des
concerts un village pour les enfants un
système de ticketing aussi en amont qui
s'adapte aussi au moyens des personnes
qui viennent voilà c'est c'est tout ça
qui a fait qu'il a réussi à en faire un
événement populaire euh et et qui va
au-delà des des fans de moto donc ça
aussi c'est des exemples qui sont qui
sont à prendre et je je voulais voilà je
voulais donner deux exemples natation et
moto qui nous sortent un peu du du
football pas de
question sur sur
eu sur euh les exigences après comment
vous les formalisez avec les les ligues
ou les organisateurs de la
compétition en règle générale je veux
dire c'est plutôt nous qui c'est plutôt
nous qui répondons à des
exigences qui sont de plus en plus
importantes qui correspondent d'ailleurs
à des progrès techniques on a parlé de
la HD la progrès aussi sur les loupes
les ralentis enfin tout tout ce qui fait
l'essentiel d'un retransmission les les
nous n'avons pas d'exigences
particulières nos seules exigences
Arnaud les a énoncé c'est c'est
l'éclairage par exemple on a une finale
de Coupe de France féminine cette année
qui doit se dérouler à
saint-briilleux et nous on voudrait pour
le football féminin puisqu'on va la
retransmettre en étant en collaboration
avec Eurosport laaffaire le soir
l'éclairage n'est pas suffisant donc ils
ont choisi alors maintenant
elle a expliqué à Monsieur Legret qui
est lui-même un élu de la région que il
va le faire à guingan chez lui au lieu
de le faire à Saint-Brieux je suis pas
du tout sûr je sais pas un politicien
mais vous ê en êtes vous imaginez vous
imaginez ce que ça peut être pour lui
hein ça c'est un vrai cas un vrai ennui
majeur donc il il il a décidé ça et sans
nous en parler sans sans nous dire
est-ce que ce stade convient alors nous
on veut valoriser cette compétition on
va peut-être être obligé de la faire
l'après-midi parce que c'est au mois de
juin où en access prime time c'estàd à
18h parce qu'il fait encore jour mais on
pourra pas le faire le soir donc sauf à
rajouter x luxe voyez donc c'est ça fait
partie des ch les exigences viennent de
chaque fois maintenant c'est j les
exigences techniques ne viennent jamais
ou les ou les les interdits techniques
ne viennent pas de notre part elles
viennent du vendeur les interdits des
interdits c'est souvent par exemple nous
demandons parce que aujourd'hui les gens
aiment être si vous voulez vous n'avez
jamais entendu la voix de photocopie
mais de Louison Bobé mais les gens
veulent maintenant dans les vestiers de
l'équipe de France on est dans un autre
monde on c'est c'est le sport trou de la
serrure pouvez pas savoir ce que les
gens se trouvent important de voir les
types en slip dans le couloir bah c'est
comme ça c'est la vie c'est et on est
obligé de faire avec et donc on demande
nous on demande à être présent on est
souvent on a des refus ou on a des
acceptations donc nous nos exigences
elles sont plutôt dans le la qualité du
spectacle la possibilité d'être dans
l'intimité des équipes au début à la
mi-temps à la fin plutôt mais les
exigences techniques rassurez-vous elles
viennent toujours du du du du
vendeur dans un contrat vous avez match
match de tel niveau 2e division tant de
caméras match de première division tant
de caméras match en prime time tant de
caméras match de l'équipe de France de
rugby ou de football tant de caméras
tant de loupe et cetera et cetera et
cetera tout est planifié ce sont des
gens qui qui font ça très très
sérieusement et qui veulent étant donné
que ils veulent que leur spectacle soit
retransmis dans les meilleures
conditions ils veulent ils ont un
certain nombre d'exigence auquell nous
répondons nous sommes plutôt dans la
réponse que dans la demande notre
demande elle concerne l'intimité du
spectacle le problème des interviews et
cetera et cetera le bord de terrain les
vestiaires notre demande elle concerne
aussi notre prê présence au plus près
des entraîneurs souvent des choses comme
ça mais ce sont des exigences
éditoriales plus que que que techniques
les exigences techniqu elles
viennent du du du vendeur pour le reste
c'est les exigences auxquelles on n'est
pas on n'est pas amené à répondre
puisque je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
de la position des caméras par exemple
dans le football britannique ou dans le
Rubby britannique mais ça c'est au
moment de la conception du stade si on
nous demande ça nous alors moi si on me
demande je vais dire voilà les caméras
je vais demander à mon directeur de la
production de dire où doivent se trouver
les caméras pour rendre compte autrement
que vu d'hélicoptère de ce qui se passe
sur le terrain alors après il y a des il
y a des il il y a des choses que nous
avons inventer nous-même ce qu'on
appelle la cabel CAM qui est au-dessus
et qui se balade au-dessus de du stade
ça c'est ça c'est des choses que nous
apportons de nous-mêmes parce que c'est
c'est des découvertes qui sont faites et
nous les essayons de les transposer sur
le terrain mais très honnêtement je
pense pas que mes mes mes camarades me
démentiront les exigences elles viennent
à 100 % du vendeur par rapport à
l'acheteur juste une réflexion parce que
nous les collectivités nos
interlocuteurs sur le terrain sont les
clubs les clubs quand elles viennent
vers les collectivités pour augmenter le
nombre de luxe ou pour prévoir un
emplacement tel endroit pour pour
rinstaller une caméra ils nous disent
mais c'est la FD ou la Ligue qui nous
l'impose et quand on interroge et ici
même dans le cadre de cette mission les
ligues ou les féd nous dit ou nous n a
pour rien ce sont les diffuseurs qui
nous l'imposent oui bah chacun pour soi
B au centrein nous si si si si si on
veut faire quelque chose de bien il faut
ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure Arnaud s'il y
a pas la lumière suffisante avec la
meilleure volonté du monde c'est pas ce
sont pas des exigences de de diva c'est
simplement si vous voulez qu'on puisse
rendre compte de votre de votre
événement il faut qu' si c'est le soir
il faut allumer la lumière grosso modo
on en est quand même là donc il y a pas
c'est pas des on a pas d'exence moi je
sais pas je on n pas on on demande pas
des choses extraordinaires parce que
tout ça c'est un coup quand je vous
disais qu'un match du tournoi
destination que j'ai annulé l'an dernier
m'a coûté 130 m'a coûté à mon groupe
130000 € je je je plaisante pas je
plaisante pas je je suis pas en train de
dire c'est à peu près ça c'est ça hein
et un match de football on va faire un
étalonnage entre nous des pris des
matchs on part de de 50 jusqu'à plus de
100 largement plus 100 largement
largement plus de 100 selon selon le
niveau du match selon le fait que c'est
le soir la journée selon le et puis il y
a un paradoxe aussi c'est que plus le
stade est petit euh plus on avir des
surcouts c'est montter des nacelles euh
c'est des câblages plus long c'est donc
c'est ça c'est aussi quelque chose alors
souvent on dit ah oui mais quand même ce
match bah oui mais c'estd que plus le on
fait déjà un effort d'aller dans les
petits stades et en plus il faut qu'on
rajoute des moyens pour pouvoir le le
traiter correctement et pour revenir à
cette sorte de poulet d'œuf là sur les
obligations en fait je pense qu'on est
un système qui se comprend parfaitement
c'està-dire que les chaînes de
télévision et je pense ça vient
particulièrement des chaînes payantes et
c'est logique monte monte en gamme la
façon de capter un événement le groupe
Canal a fait ce un excellent travail
notamment sur le football et le rugby en
proposant des caméras supplémentaires
des angles nouveaux et donc les
fédérations et les li se l'approprient
pour les mettre en minimum standard dans
l'appel d'offre d'après donc on est dans
une sorte de course à l'échalotte un
petit peu oui oui et à mon avis ça va ça
va pas s'arrêter parce que j'imagine que
B aussi est plein de créativité
d'innovation va peut-être trouver une
petite astuce qui va plaire à la Ligue
et dans le prochain appel d'offre ce qui
était une petite astuce une nouveauté
ben ça va être écrit noir sur blanc
comme une obligation maintenant pour les
pour les chaînes ça peut expliquer que
tout le monde se renvoie la balle mais
n'empêche que infin c'est quand même ce
qui est ce qui est dans le contrat
d'appel d'offre qui doit être respecté
même si les télévisions il faut quand
même le reconnaître on leur parle de
responsabilité dans cette volonté de
d'être mieux mieux disant visuellement
voilà c'est tout l'humour de la
situation c'est-à-dire que chaque chaîne
essaie d'améliorer sa retransmission et
au prochain appel d'offre on essaie de
nous faire payer plus cher le produit
quoi
euh on est d'accord sur cette notion de
spectacle sportif donc en direction des
spectateurs mais des
téléspectateurs donc dans euh cette
nécessité de faire vivre et d'améliorer
encore ce spectacle sportif je pense que
vous avez un rôle essentiel à jouer
euh parmi les éléments qui vont faire
que c'est un spectacle attractif vendeur
à l'étranger et cetera il y a ben
l'intérêt de la compétition j'imagine
tout à l'heure donné l'exemple du
bolchoy en cblant le
paris-germain aujourd'hui on a
effectivement le risque d'avoir un
championnat bon qui perd un peu sa
saveur parce que à la fin de
l'année on va savoir si c'est le
parisgermain ou Monaco mais pendant tout
le long de la saison comme vous avez dit
ça sera une démonstration faite par ces
deux clubs donc dans leur tournée de de
championnat
euh justement peut-être que un des
éléments qui peut faire que le
championnat ne sera pas à deux vitesses
c'est la répartition des droit
télévision et est-ce que là vous avez un
mot à dire est-ce que vous souhaitez
avoir un mot à dire est-ce que la clé de
répartition aujourd'hui telle qu'elle
est en France elle accroit pas cette
différence de niveau entre les clubs qui
arrivent premier et les autres qui
suivent parce qu'on a vu ce qui se
faisait en Angleterre la clé de
répartition est beaucoup plus égalitaire
en Allemagne également qu'en France et
je pense que ça ça participe quand même
au nivellement peut-être du niveau de
championnat et donc au spectacle sportif
qui demain peut être mieux valorisé par
vous voilà est-ce que vous voulez être
partie prenante est-ce que vous vous
souhaitez être partie prenante dans la
répartition des droits télé ça
m'étonnerait qu'on nous y autorise he
honnêtement là jeis je vois pas les les
ligues professionnelles nous autoriser à
dire un mot
là-dedans la répartition elle est elle
est très importante la répartition des
droits télévisés en France parce que
notamment pour le pour pour c'est moi
moins vrai pour le rugby c'est très vrai
pour le football le sort des clubs
dépend beaucoup de des droits télévisés
alors que dans d'autres pays la
billetterie est un élément extrême plus
la billetterie est un élément important
moins le problème des droits télévisés
se pose et dans le football le problème
des droits télévisés se pose à l'extrême
parce que le football est très dépendant
est très dépendant c'est pour ça que je
vous citer l'exemple de de l'utilisation
de l'argent la la la première année
après la signature d'un bon contrat avec
un diffuseur on achète des joueurs et
puis petit àtit on réduit en se disant
la prochaine fois peut-être que le
contrat soit moins intéressant et la
dernière année vous voyez des ventes
avant avant avant les le renouvellement
vous voyez toujours des ventes en se
disant au moins si on renouvelle dans de
mauvaises conditions j'aurais pas euh
une un budget salarial trop important
toujours comme ça toujours comme ça
regardez regardez bien sauf l'exception
de ces deux clubs dont on parle là qui
n'ont pas les mêmes contraintes mais
pour les autres c'est comme ça je pense
qu'on nous demandera jamais rien enfin
je parle sous le contrôle de mes amis on
ne demandera jamais rien dans ce domaine
et qu'est-ce que nous avons à dire nous
on a on a si c'est l'intérêt des des
diffuseurs parce que derrière il peut y
avoir aussi en en deuxème étape pardon
je sais pas si c'est l'intérêt des
diffuseurs aussi et si c'est leur
travail de se mêler de la redistribution
financière des clubs je pense qu'en tant
que diffuseur et là on parle du football
parce que c'est surtout là que c'est
important il faut surtout pas que cette
redistribution rentre en compte et on va
dire oblige une certaine programmation
c'est-à-dire que le diffuseur doit être
libre de pouvoir programmer l'affiche le
match qu'il souhaite pour telle ou telle
raison une histoire une mais la la
redistribution financière de ne doit pas
impacter comme à une certaine époque la
programmation des matchs en tout cas moi
en tant que diffuseur et on parle de la
Ligue 1 je pense pas que le rôle d'un
diffuseur soit de rentrer dans le calcul
de la
redistribution un diffuseur paye des
droits qu'il estime est le prix avec
évidemment un vendeur ensuite chacun son
métier le diffuseur met en valeur essaie
de le programmer de la meilleure des
façons le produire de la meilleure des
façons pour remplir les stades donc pour
remplir les stades ça passe aussi par la
programmation en tant que telle c'est le
jour l'heure mais pas de rentrer dans ce
dans ce débat là c'est chacun son job
quoi la seule chose que que peut
demander un diffuseur qui a payé cher ou
très cher c'est dans la répartition de
la diffusion des mches que qu'il puisse
faire ses choix c'est-à-dire qu'on lui
oppose pas une sorte d'égalité il faut
passer tant de fois tel club tant de
fois tel club à égalité parce que le le
rendement de de certains clubs est
moindre que celui d'autres clubs donc il
faut pouvoir exiger exiger obtenir d'une
ligue que le le choix des des matchs à
diffuser à certaines heures soit le
libre arbitre des des des diffuseur
sinon le système égalitaire n'aurait
n'aurait pas de
sens parle aussi beaucoup de la capacité
des stades mais il faut aussi à mon avis
intégrer si on se compare à nos
homologues européens à la qualité des
plouses parce que ça c'est aussi des
coûts typiquement on le voit en
Angleterre on joue le 25 décembre par
exemple en France en Allemagne très peu
voire quasiment de report de match ça
n'existe pas en France énormément de
reports de match et ça ça impacte qui en
premier c'est les diffuseurs typiquement
quand vous achetez un match en primetime
euh ça a une certaine valeur dans dans
le montant des droits euh ce ce match là
un vendredi soir ou un samedi soir ça a
une certaine valeur c'est comme ça qu'on
fixe les droits et la valeur des droits
d'un d'une compétition euh en France on
est habitué souvent à pour telle et
telle raison Daniel évoquait tout à
l'heure la l'annulation l'année dernière
d'un match à si je me souviens bien
c'était à 5 minutes du coup d'envoi
pratiquement euh est-ce que le froid est
arrivé d'un coup est-ce que c'est des
choses qui auraient pas pu être anticipé
parce que peut-être qu'il y a des
assurances etci et là donc on oublie
souvent dans ce cas de figure là le
diffuseur on parle de l'enceinte du
nombre de places c'est sûr que si on
peut avoir des enceintes les plus
grandes possibles les plus belles les
mieux éclairés les plus remplies mais à
un moment donné il faut qu'il y ait une
pelouse de qualité pour la qualité de
jeu et surtout pour éviter à un moment
donné les reports de match souvent des
reports de match avec des difficultés de
programmation de
reprogrammation beaucoup de compétitions
en France euh cet exemple hier soir pas
plus tard qu'hier le match Bordeaux
Lorient qui avait été déplacé et
reprogrammé hier face à de la Champions
League donc là je parle pour ma paroisse
également sur bein vous vous retrouvez
avec deux événements que vous payez très
cher et que vous optimisez pas au
maximum Bordeaux le stade était à moitié
vide et en terme d'audience et en terme
de de valorisation de cet événement le
diffuseur s'y retrouve pas donc il y a
aussi ça à intégrer dans quand on
appelle l'enceinte sportive c'est à la
fois la capacité mais c'est aussi la
qualité du du terrain ça passe par des
pelouses ça passe par du du chauffage
intégré voilà on voit qu'en Angleterre
on joue même en plein hiver il y a très
peu de report en France beaucoup de
reports et c'est un problème pour les
pour les diffuseur en tout cas pour nous
be qui diffusons 80 % de la Ligue 1 et
90 % de la Ligue 2 tous les weekends
c'est vrai que quand tu arrive là tant
mieux on n pas encore vu trop l'hiver
arriver mais quand arrive la période du
mois de décembre janvier je peux vous
dire qu'on regarde plus les bulletins
météo le vendredi soir
que le le journal de 20h pour savoir ce
qui se passe dans le
monde je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
ça il y a d'autres éléments aussi qui
font que programmer un match de football
devient quand même de plus en plus
compliqué il y a c'est effectivement cet
état des pelouses et à chaque fois bah
un match qui est annulé quelques minutes
avant ça nous est arrivé aussi sur la
Coupe de France cette année bah c'est
euh voilà c'est des dizaines et dizaines
de milliers d'euros qui ben qu'on peut
pas récupérer donc ça c'est quand même
un souci il y a a il y a d'autres
phénomènes qu'on voit et c'est ce fameux
principe je le respecte et en même temps
je pense qu'il faut qu'on y fasse
attention c'est le principe de
précaution donc dans les deux dernière
saison n on a tout eu donc évidemment on
a eu l'OB qui qui qui était en
possibilité de de déb de débordement
d'inondation donc le match à 3 été
reporté vous avez des des choses moi qui
m'étonnent toujours un petit peu plus je
me su un match au Man et pourtant des
match la M Arena il y en a quand même
pas tous les 36 qui qui ont vraiment un
intérêt actuellement malheureusement on
nous a expliqué qu'on voulait programmer
un match je crois que c'était Sablé sur
SAR d'ailleurs qui s'était délocalisé en
Coupe de France qu' elle accueillit le
PSG le club aue le PSG à la même Arena
on pouvait pas programmer le match en
prime time parce que le même soir il y
avait un match de basket juste à côté
donc là on nous dit service de
préfecture on est désolé et on le
respecte he mais on sait pas gérer la
sécurité l'accueil en terme de force de
police de deux événements sportifs en
même temps et je sais et je crois savoir
mais peut-être flurent tu peux me
confirmer que c'est un peu la même chose
si vous avez un match du PSG à domicile
ou un match et un match du Stade
Français à jambin euh parce que nous on
a eu le cas sur laaming Cup a priori on
nous recommande de ne pas programmer de
faire en sorte que les matchs soient pas
le le même soir donc ça c'est quand même
euh ça peut être quand même un souci euh
on a même eu alors ça on y pouvait rien
on a eu je pas si vous souvenez le
l'incident dans l'usine de de rouan là
qui avait euh avec voilà des émanations
toxiques que donc il y a toujours plein
d'exemples c'est juste pour vous
expliquer que parfois ce qu'on imagine
pas arrive et finalement on se retrouve
à avoir des contraintes de programmation
qui sont de plus en plus plus en plus
importantes pas toujours lié uniquement
uniquement à ce qui peut se passer à ce
qui peut ce qui peut se passer dans le
stade et je rajoute à ça le principe de
précaution de sécurité qui dans un
certain nombre de cas se comprend tout à
fait là par exemple on a on pouvait pas
programmer un match Montpellier
saint-étierre donc Cann Saint-Étienne
excusez-moi en Coupe de France parce que
on voulait que le match programme en
durne donc ça c'est c'est aussi une mode
qui se développe qu'on comprend mais bon
voilà les préfets dès qu'il a un petit
risque disent bon on fait le match en
durne comme ça on est plus tranquille
parfois ça se justifie parfois il faut
savoir que voilà c'est dommageable aussi
pour l'exposition d'un match voir même
pour sa diffusion tout court et c'est
aussi des éléments qui se rajoutent dans
la difficulté de de programmation qu'on
peut qu'on peut rencontrer au au
quotidien alors pour compléter ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure sur les sujets de
de clés de répartition ce que j'aiévoqué
sur attention aux fausses bonnes idées
en fait c'est
euh une première fausse bonne idée
c'était de dire attention si l'équipe
est trop forte ça va déséquilibrer il y
aura plus d'intérêt on voit que le
championnat d'Espagne avec le Real et le
Barça sont extrêmement puissants c'est
pareil en au Portugal avec Porto c'est
par dans finalement finalement dans tous
les championnats et ça n'empêche pas ces
championnats d'être passionnants et être
intéressant
on peut sur le même principe on peut
regarder ce que faisait le PSG quand il
était moyen en taux de remplissage à
l'extérieur et ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui
s'il est ultra dominant au moment où on
se parle il génère des taux de
remplissage incroyable à l'extérieur
donc il y a un rôle de locomotive et le
problème n'est surtout pas que les gros
soient trop gros c'est de ne pas avoir
de gros ça encore fautil que les petits
puissent vivre aussi parce que ça c'est
le problème de l'Espagne entre autres de
de l'Italie de l'Espagne il a il y a un
sujet d'équilibre et justement sur ce
sujet d'équilibre il faut faire
attention à deux choses c'est à ne pas
être trop équilibré trop équilibré ça a
été la France des années 90 et
finalement en étant trop équilibré on
affaiblissé nos nos représentants dans
les compétitions européennes et donc on
était pas performant et quand on n pas
performant au niveau européen bah on a
du mal à voir une fierté pour ces clubs
parce que on sait que dès qu'ils vont
au-dessus ils vont prendre des des des
fessés euh et donc ça pour le la fierté
de du supporter c'est un peu difficile
et le et et l'autre phénomène par
rapport à ça c'est c'est de garder à
l'esprit que la complexité de ce système
c'est que c'est un système à deux étages
vous avez une compétition nationale et
une compétition continentale et donc il
faut trouver le bon équilibre entre la
répartition qui permet au petits d'avoir
assez pour vivre et au gros d'être
d'avoir assez pour être compétitif
au-dessus et à ce niveau-là euh vous
avez parlé de l'Angleterre mais la
France est un modèle et un des modèles
d'équilibre avec l'Allemagne également
le vrai déséquilibre c'est en Espagne et
en
italietin oui merci monsieur le
Président c'est vrai qu'à travers les
propos des uns et des autres on imagine
comprend bien la difficulté du problème
mais en fait vous êtes diffuseur de
spectacle hein diffuseur de spectacle où
il y a pas mal de partenaires pas mal
d'acteurs il y a il faut d'abord un
équipement pour qu' ait le spectacle cet
équipement bien souvent en France dépend
de la municipalité et là ça suppose des
relations entre la Fédération la ligne
et la municipalité car les uns ceux qui
payent pas en généralement généralement
sont exigeants par rapport à ceux qui P
et c'est un vrai problème qu'essie de
régler la MF c'est-à-dire l'Association
des maires de France car c'est vrai nous
sommes dans un pays extraordinaire moins
on paye plus on exige al c'est comme ça
puis c'est tout et puis derrière il y a
ce qu'on appelle le spectacle le
spectacle est nécessaire je crois que
mon milalien l'a fort bien dit nous
n'avons pas le même esprit que
l'Angleterre hein mais néanmoins
néanmoins il y a des villes où on a
fidélisé fidélisé les spectateur c'est
là où il y a eu des résultats c'était le
Racing à une époque le grand reince et
avec les accidents qui peuvent arriver
car on s'est aperçu que Reims a descendu
on oubliait un peu reince reince est
ressorti l'histoire ressort en quelque
sorte il y a les vers il y a Lyon
maintenant c'est le Racing le Racing le
PSG et c'est vrai comme je disais avec
mon collègue il faut de grands clubs de
grands clubs qui attirent la foule qui
font le spectacle qui sont nécessaires
alors l'un des problèmes qu'on a en
France c'est la taxation aussi de ces
clubs car je voyais c'était aujourd'hui
me semble-t-il ou hier que Marseille va
devoir payer 4 millions d'euros de
réintégration si j'ose dire je vais
appeler ça comme ça avec cet argent on
aurait pu améliorer l'équipement
l'équipement est en train d'être
réhabilité à Marseille 4 millions de
plus d'euros ça peut se voir et on a ça
dans de nombreux clubs comme
Saint-Étienne comme le Paris SG comme
bien d'autres alors ce spectacle c'est
vrai que l'on souhaite qu'il soit ouvert
à tous qu'il soit ouvert aux familles
qu'il soit ouvert à un public
inconditionnel parce que ils aiment ça
puis ça fait passer un moment et les
heures elles peuvent avoir une
importance mais pas tant que ça quand on
aime je dois dire c'est un peu ce que
l'on dit on compte pas quoi que nous
nous comptons souvent mais quand on aime
on va voir parce que et alors ce et
alors existe un problème c'est le
problème bien entendu du PSG à l'heure
actuelle don tout le monde est content
de le voir partout où il passe il fait
le plein mais alors on entend des
réflexions dernièrement c'était me
semble-t-il sur le terrain du président
de la Fédération on disait il jouit sur
une marapoule quoi hein bon le stade
n'était pas dans un état et on vous dit
mais oui mais la qualité du spectacle on
a subi des conséquences alors il y a
tout à voir il y a tout à voir et
comment faire au mieux puisque me
semble-t-il à travers ce que vous faites
c'est-à-dire ce qui est donné comme
enveloppe pour obtenir des matchs il y a
moins en France qu'en Angleterre qu'en
Allemagne quand je vois quand même qu'
en Angleterre on parle d'e participation
des télés à hauteur de plusieurs
millions de milliards pardon en France
nous sommes à quelques centaines de
millions quand même c'est pas si mal
mais ça veut dire que nous-mêmes
vous-même vous dévalorisez le le
championnat français puisque il ne
semble pas mériter autant que les matchs
en Angleterre que les matchs en Espagne
ou même que les matchs en Italie alors
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'en France il a un public un public
qui souhaite avoir de la qualité dans
les matchs et je crois que bien souvent
ça se résume à ça la qualité la qualité
et la qualité entraîne bien entendu le
spectateur entraîne les télés aussi qui
aime ça et Monsieur villalian quand il
les spectateur il doivver ça je le vois
par des presses fréquemment et c'est
vrai que quand un match ma foi a été à
la limite comme on dit ah la fois
d'après on revient peut-être par
habitude mais si on a été enchanté on
revient en courant il y a un peu tout ça
à mêler et faire en sorte qu'en France
puisque nous nous voulons aussi occuper
les premières places et faire en sorte
qu'en France nous puissions au niveau
européen être dans les premiers mais ça
dépend avant tout me semble-t-il des
financements car on en a bien la preuve
de clubs émergent en France à l'heure
actuelle c'est le PSG c'est Monaco ce
sont deux clubs dont les budgets ont
explosé par rapport aux autres c'est la
démonstration que sans argent on ne peut
rien avec l'argent on n'est pas sûr du
résultat on n'est jamais sûr on a la
preuve avec Arsenal
qui est un bel exemple car Arsenal a
décidé à un moment donné de refaire son
son stade ils ont refait le stade ils
ont un gestionnaire qui s'appelle Vanger
je crois et bien il a dû limiter les
achats de joueurs limitant les achats de
joueurs il s'est retrouvé à un moment où
presque ça allait être la culbute
c'est-à-dire que les résultats étaient
insuffisants par rapport à l'espoir des
des spectateurs et des téléspectateurs
mais voilà qu'il a franchi ce moment et
que il a pu se repayer en quelque sorte
des joueurs pour occuper le haut du
tableau et si jamais il arrive à la
finalité de son Paris c'est-à-dire être
champion d'Angleterre il aura fait la
démonstration de ce qui est imaginable
et de ce qu'on pourrait prendre comme
exemple en France si vous venez de notre
côté pour nous expliquer que nous payons
pas assez cher vous risquez de passer un
un sale moment là je vous conseille pas
de venir de ce côté-ci de la table
euh non non la dit l' dit l' dit la
différence là on parle de ces deux on
parle de ces deux clubs la différence
entre je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure la
différence entre le Real Madrid et
Barcelone qui sont des clubs
antagonistes depuis très longtemps elles
ont ce sont ce sont des clubs qui ont
j'allais dire qui sont endettés mais qui
ont vécu comme des clubs ordinaires avec
la volonté d'un retour sur
investissement même s'ils ne l'ont pas
c'est le cas en Grande-Bretagne c'est le
cas en Allemagne pour ce qui concerne
les deux clubs dont nous parlons en
France et que nousons pas c'est ABS
absolument pas des gens qui attendent un
retour sur investissement c'est un
investissement politique c'est-à-dire
que moi je suis le meilleur businessman
du monde quand je rentre au pays que
j'ai dépensé une certaine somme et que
je fais la l unee de l'équipe ça me
suffit alors que moi on me dit quand
vous avez investi 100 faut rapporter 110
quand à Monaco c'est l'exception qui
confirme la règle c'est le fait du
prince enfin pas du prince de Monaco
mais d' d'un d'un d'un parachic en exil
donc c'est ça la différence entre des
clubs historiques comme Barcelone je
suis d'accord et Madrid qui domine le
championnat espagnol ou Manchester et al
qui domine ou Chelsea qui domine le
football anglais mais ce sont pas des
investissements de nature encore que
pour Chelsea ce soit un investissement
de de cette nature la seule différence
c'est que chez nos amis chez nos amis
anglais les anglais sont des protestants
et donc ils ont par rapport à l'argent
une autre attitude que la notre le plus
la date la plus terrible de l'histoire
de France c'est quand même la révocation
de l de Nant on est bien d'accord
hein simplement pour quand même revenir
sur c'est on paye beaucoup d'argent
quand même pour les droits faut quand
même le rappeler je pense que c'est pas
si éloigné que ça que les autres
championnats en tout cas nous on diffuse
pas de championnat mais on on paye assez
cher les droits de l'équipe de France on
est ravi d'avoir l'équipe de France
diffusée sur TF1
mais je pense que vous le savez tous
nous ne gagnons pas d'argent quand nous
achetons des droits si on met en regard
les recettes autour de ces match on ne
gagne pas d'argent bon c'est notre
problème et on est encore une fois ravi
de les diffuser mais je pense qu'il faut
aussi remettre les choses et ce que j'ai
essayé de d'expliquer tout à l'heure
mais en France on est très dépendant et
par exemple le foot français est très
dépendant des droits télé c'est plus de
55 % voire 60 % des recettes et des du
chiffre d'affaires dansc le
professionnel c'est pas le cas en
Angleterre alors il gagnent plus
d'argent si si les chaînes donnent
encore plus d'argent il sera encore plus
dépendant donc il faut un peu sortir de
cette dépendance par rapport au droits
télé essayer de construire un modèle
économique qui fonctionne et qui soit
équilibré un modèle économique équilibré
c'est jamais un seul un seul fournisseur
donc euh un seul un seul endroit où sont
focalisés les RET c'est-à-dire les
droits de télé je pense que c'est
probablement un mauvais calcul et on
donne encore une fois beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent au sport français on est ravi
de le donner mais on peut pas toujours
demander aux chaînes de télé d'en faire
plus et en donner plus il faut aussi que
les club de sport que les fédérations
que les ligues prennent leur
responsabilités et construisent un
modèle économique
100 à l'euro à l'euro pour l'Euro aucun
aucun diffuseur ne va vous dire qu'il se
rembourse sur sur un achat en revanche
la manière de se rembourser d'un
événement sportif pour pour un groupe
comme le nôtre c'est sur l'année
enregistrer une part de marché
supplémentaire qui fait que à la fin de
l'année votre régie publicitaire sur
l'ensemble des programmes vend du 15 du
20 % au lieu de vendre du 14 ou du 19
par exemple les Jeux Olympiques que nous
venons de diffuser là pendant pendant 15
jours ou encore ce d'été de Londres il y
a il y a 2 ans maintenant ont en un seul
mois augmenté la part d'audience globale
de France 2 d'un point sur 15 jours d'un
point sur l'annéed dire que cette
année-là je crois que l'année 2013 le le
France 2 devait descendre autour de 14
et est resté à 15 % de part de marché
donc la régie publicitaire
commercialement ensuite auprès des
annonceur vend du 15 au lieu de vendre
du 14 mais à l'euro pour l'Euro si vous
vous remboursez d'un gros tiers
c'est le bout du monde c'est le bout du
monde mais pas la moitié la moitié non
je pense pas je pense pas démenti en
disant que un gros tiers c'est c'est
vraiment le maximum
et première minute il finit le film
tandis que nous on peut acheter Brad pit
et qu'il aille certains ici s'en
souviennent moi comme d'autres et que
Brad pit il Meur vraiment au bout de 5
minutes c'est le cas de l'équipe de
France dans la dernière Coupe du monde
où les championnats d'Europe juste pour
rebondir sur sur ce que vous venez de
d'évoquer concernant la dépendance un
peu des clubs français sur les droits TV
on voit que dans d'autres pays la
répartition est un peu plus équilibrée
entre la billetterie le sponsoring mais
aussi tout ce qui est dans l'animation
des stades or on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on l'a visité on a aussi
entendu aussi bien au niveau de l'Arena
92 qu'au niveau du du du stade de la
Fédération française de
rugby des rentrées d'argent
sont prévu avec d'autres activités
concert et autres est-ce que le
développement de c'est pas beaucoup le
cas actuellement en France les stades
sont essentiellement uniquement destinés
à l'activité
sportive mais on voit que les choses
sont en train d'évoluer dans les
nouveaux équipements on va avoir bien
sûr beaucoup de de manifestations et du
sport à l'intérieur ce sera pas
l'événement majeur est-ce que cette
évolution des équipements stade mais
aussi arenna vous inquiète vous est-ce
que c'est quelque chose par au niveau de
la diffusion au niveau de la
programmation le fait que vous serez
aussi dépendant de d'autres activités
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
gérable facilement pour
vous non pas
particulièrement le seul problème c'est
qu'encore faut-il que ce soit réaliste
c'estàd beaucoup de business
planans de dans C indoor ou même de
stade outdoor se base effectivement sur
un certain nombre d'événements sportifs
plus des événements culturels ou des
grands con
sauf que T quasiment les équipements qui
ont qui qui qui réalisent ce type de
business plan ont à peu près ce même
modèle sauf que vous après vous regardez
qui est capable artistiquement de
remplir ses enceintes donc en France
c'est simple c'est milen Farmer Johnny
ALID Indochine vous avez pas un autre
artiste qui peut rempire un stade en
France voilà et les artistes
internationaux Dépêche Mode a voulu
jouer à l'île l'île est pas chauffé donc
le concert a été annulé parce
qu'apparemment donc ça demanderait
confirmation semblerait que le système
de chauffage en réalité n'est pas activé
dans le nouveau stade dans le grand
stade à lillele et les artistes
internationaux c'est pareil vous en avez
pas 50 par an qui vont être enentournés
et qui vont passer en France François
qui connaît bien la musique le sait bien
là aussi ça se compte sur les les doigs
d'une main je vous répondrai à donc de
deux façons en vous disant non ça nous
inquiète pas parce qu'en réalité je
pense que ce nombre de d'événements
culturels artistiques ou de concert ne
sont pas si nom que ça en tous les cas
pas capable de remplir à la fois tous
les stades et tous les business plans
tels qu' sont présentés des nouvelles
enceintes sportives c'est mon avis
Pierre Martin alin nie et puis
après pu le président merci je constate
une chose certainement comme beaucoup
d'entre vous c'est que les stades de
football sont en train quand même de se
vider d'un certain nombre de
spectateurs et globalement le nombre de
spectateurs tel qu' il est constaté par
les la Fédération par la Ligue le nombre
global de de spectateurs est en
diminution c'est une réalité en
particulier c'est ce que nous onons les
chiffres qu'on nous a donné alors si
c'est faux il faudra nous donner les
chiffres vrais en tous les cas sur le
rugby je sais que ça augmente ça c'est
certain Top 14 sur le Top 14 ça augmente
FO aussi en Ligue 1 alors c'est vrai que
c'est peut-être pas la croissance qu'on
pourrait espérer ça c'est possible bon
ben écoutez vous nous fournirez les
chiffres ça sera très intéressant de
deuxièmement la question qui se pose et
qui parfois n nous
indispose c'est que pour faire
effectivement du chiffre
de d' d'audition d'audimat il y a des
programmations de match à des heures qui
ne correspondent pas forcément au
souhait des des
spectateurs en particulier on nous dit
si on a eu ce problème en Ligue 2 où il
fallait programmer les les matchs le
vendredi à 18h ou c'est pas forcément
oui je sais bien ça peut
intéresser ça peut ne pas intéresser
beaucoup mais ça peut ne pas intéresser
les Parisiens enfin les les les
provinciaux ont aussi droit à avoir un
spectacle sportif de temps en temps
surtout quand ça met à contribution les
finances de de leur collectivité local
et donc dans c'est oui d'accord mais la
France c'est pas uniquement Paris avec
un peu de T retour faudra bien vous
mettre ça dans la tête et en particulier
je crois que il faudrait être attentif à
une chose c'est que la programmation des
matchs se fasse en fonction de l'intérêt
sportif surtout et quand on déplace en
particulier le résultat d'un match le
par l'horaire d'un match quand il y a
une compétition serrée ça peut jouer
sur le résultat parce que quand on
connait le résultat à l'avance du match
du concurrent ça peut poser un certain
nombre de problèmes donc je crois que
là-dessus il faudrait qu'on soit
vigilant et deuxièmement vous posiez le
problème de de diffusion de cinter match
mais écoutez quand il y a un match de
Coupe de France on peut pas savoir à
l'avance puisque c'est l'incertitude du
match par élimination directe de qui va
jouer contre qui et vous donz l' exemple
du man par contre le match du basket du
man lui en championnat de France il
était programmé de longue date puisqu'on
savait que c'était ce jourl que le match
vait se jouer donc c'est la c'est les
aléas je comprends ce que je voulais
juste dire je m'étonnais que une ville
comme le Man qui est quand même une
ville sportive avec un d' SC ne soit pas
capable de supporter l'organisation le
même soir d'un match de football d'un
match de basket c'était ça ma plutôt ma
voilà c'était oui c'est peut-être ça le
problème c'est peutêre c'était peut-être
aussi le problème vous savez leement ils
ont quand même quelques difficultés pour
remplir les stades aujourd'hui donc
c'était quelque chose d'intéressant qu'
un match de Coupe de France qui puisse
remplir le stade mais il aurait
peut-être été aussi intelligent qu' une
concertation et que le match de de Coupe
de France puisse être décalé par rapport
au match de basket mais concertation il
y a mais il y a beaucoup de paramètres
c'est pas toujours facile et et
simplement moi
je ma dernière question mais les plus
direct c'est par rapport au droits
télé parce que les droits de télé
effectivement c'est la MAN alors on peut
se poser la question certains de nos
collègues ont dit il faut augmenter les
droits télé j'ai senti que Monsieur
Bilalian était très réservé là-dessus il
a dit pour aller vendre cette
proposition il va falloir vraiment avoir
un très bon avocat mais je me demande
moi-même si on n'est pas en train
d'arriver à un sommet au niveau de
l'argent qui circule qui devrait pas
être quand même un petit peu contrôlé
parce que je crains qu'un jour il la
bulle elle explose ça pourra pas durer
inéternable cette inflation cette
augmentation
euh
exponentielle des droits de télé qu'on
vous demande et de l'argent qui circule
dans le football et dans le sport d'une
façon générale moi je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui
on le constate bien à travers les
budgets de la Jeunesse des sports qui
sont des budgets à 019 020 du du budget
de la France d'ailleurs quel que soit
les gouvernement ça c'est tranquille on
est à peu près au même niveau tout le
temps
donc et par contre il y a donc pas assez
d'argent pour le sport mais il y a
peut-être à certain moment trop d'argent
dans le sport et que on avait réussi une
petite chose il y a quelques années
faisant reverser une partie des droits
télé touché par les clubs professionnels
sur le le sport amateur je me demande
s'il y aurait pas là une réflexion
profonde àener toujours la taxe buffet
oui oui non mais le
problème et les fédérations
elle est payée par les ligues et les
fédérations lorsque les droits sont
achetés en France mais la particularité
d'un projet d'ailleurs qui a été rejeté
récemment c'est sur les droits que nous
payons en Suisse en Angleterre par
exemple moi je pay le tournoi
destination à Dublin et bien comme
l'état français ne pouvait pas approcher
euh ces ces organisateur c'était
l'acheteur qui devait encore payer la
taxe buffet c'est-à-dire que l'acheteur
payait la taxe qu'aurait dû que le que
le vendeur aurait dû payer heureusement
il y a quand même quelqu'un qui a été à
peu près raisonnable et qui a dit non
c'est pas possible je crois je sais pas
c'est le Conseil constitutionnel ou le
Conseil d'État qui a dit non on peut pas
faire payer à l'acheteur ce qui devrait
être payé par le par par le vendeur mais
on n était pas loin hein comme on ne
peut et c'est et moi j'ai dit à ce
moment-là quandad madame FOURNERON nous
a nous a sollicité là-dessus je lui ai
dit écoutez c'est simple nous on va se
débrouiller euh pour éviter que
d'acheter des choses à l'étranger donc
vous serez privé d'un certain nombre de
choses par exemple tout ce qui est
athlétisme se
déroule est installé en Suisse tout ce
qui est football est installé en Suisse
tout ce qui est rugby est installé en
Irlande donc il y avait quelque chose
d'assez d'assez d'assez abérrant mais je
vais laisser euh sur la Florent répond
sur le problème des des horaires sur la
les problèmes des horaires et notamment
de la Ligue 2 un problème que àin sport
on connaît bien puisqu'on a été très
vite accusé taxé de vouloir la mort de
la Ligue 2 en programmant les matchs à
18h45 ou 18h30 dans un premier temps euh
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure il faut
se rappeler qu'au départ les les appels
d'offre ce ne sont pas les téléviseurs
les télévisions les diffuseurs qui les
fixent sont les ligues qui évidemment
peuvent en amont essayer de travailler
avec évidemment les clubs mais aussi les
diffuseurs et essayer de trouver quelque
chose de cohérent euh donc cet appel
d'offre de Ligue 2 est arrivé chez les
différents diffuseurs avec une case
horaire le vendredi à 18h30 ou 18h45 il
y avait une simple raison c'est que
parfois souvent la Ligue 2 on est en
région en province avec parfois aussi
des matchs le vendredi soir de Ligue 1 à
20h ou 20h30 donc l'idée au départ
c'était d'essayer de de pas mettre la
Ligue 2 et la Ligue 1 en concurrence
donc c'est un peu réfléchi aussi comme
démarche euh effectivement on a fait
quelques mois euh je crois que c'est 4
ou 5 mois à 18h45 euh évidemment on on
diffusait pas l'image de lit 2
gratuitement il y a eu un certain nombre
de de droit c'était valorisé c'est pas
500000 € c'était au-delà de 10 millions
d'euros donc c'est c'est de l'argent
quand même sans oublier la production
qu'on doit rajouter sur l'ensemble des
matchs produits euh on s'est retrouvé à
diffuser des matchs avec des banderolles
anti BeIn Sport euh bon au niveau de la
bienvenue c'est pas ce qu'il y a de
mieux quand même euh ensuite on nous a
dit vous
pas oui mais en tout cas au niveau local
au niveau politique au niveau même des
présidents et des acteurs du monde du
sport ça serait bien de temps en temps
de pas non plus toujours taper sur les
diffuseurs et ou en tout cas inciter les
clubs de supporters en rebalançant la
patacho je dirais de la responsabilité
euh à 18h30 on nous a accusé de vider et
de baisser la moyenne d'affluence dans
les stades de Ligue 2 euh ce en quoi
c'était pas vrai puisque entre la saison
précédente avec des matchs un peu plus
tard et la phase de 4 ou 5 mois de début
de saison à
18h45 la l'affluence des stades de Ligue
2 n'avait pas baissé ça c'est factuel
c'est des chiffres qui sont consultables
à la LFP c'est c'est factuel ensuite
puisqu'on est des gens on va dire on se
considère les diffuseurs la plupart du
temps comme des partenaires c'est-à-dire
qu'à un moment donné il faut qu'on soit
les uns et les autres en phase on a mais
avec la Ligue des discussions on a même
trouvé un compromis c'est nous qui avons
proposé ce compromis de diffuser les le
multiplex de Ligue 2 à 20h c'est quand
même pratiquement 1 he15 1h de0 plus
tard euh vous connaissez les résultats
des affluences ça n'a rien changé on le
mettrait à 21h ça changera rien donc il
faut pas non plus
constamment trouver le seul responsable
en l'occurrence le diffuseur qui ne paye
pas assez cher euh programme mal euh et
voilà donc là c'est factuel c'est la
réalité les 6 premiers mois à 18h45 la
même affluence que l'année d'avant et là
en ayant décalé à 20h avec une
concurrence de Ligue 1 et même pour nous
en tant que diffuseur c'était pas la
solution idéale en terme de
programmation parce que vous mettez à la
même heure un produit Ligue 1 d'un match
premium le soir et en face sur bin 2 la
Ligue 2 le multiplex bon ben on le fait
parce que on considère que c'était une
demande
et que de toute manière on est là aussi
pour essayer d'avancer et d'essayer de
trouver et de d'essayer d'avoir les
solutions à tous les problèmes
visiblement ce n'était pas un problème
de case horaire c'est autre chose il
faut y réfléchir en tout cas je pense
que heureusement que la Ligue 2
aujourd'hui à un diffuseur et deux
diffuseurs comme Eurosport et bein
France parce que et BeIn Sport parce que
c'est quand même des de l'argent qui
rentre dans les caises de d'éc de Ligue
2 et certains auraient peut-être pu
déposer de bilan s'il n'y avait pas eu
de diffuseur de Ligue 2 ça c'est
important de le dire aussi je voudrais
quand même rajouter une chose c'est que
on a on travaille beaucoup sous
contrainte on a aussi nous un modèle
économique à faire vivre
et on a des contraintes très fortes de
la part des aant droit dans les appels
d'offres on a peu de marge de manœuvre
on en parlé sur l'installation des
caméras mais c'est aussi vrai dans un
cadre réglementaire français qui est
très contraint on peut pas montrer de
sponsors de de produits dans les pour
les sponsors les ayant droit maintenant
parfois nous impos eux même leurs
sponsors donc on a aussi nous des
contraintes de monétisation de ces
droits qui sont une réalité et qui euh
doivent rentrer en ligne de compted que
on a des dépenses en face il faut un
moment qu'il y ait quand même un tout
petit peu de recette même s'il y en a
très peu aujourd'hui par rapport à ce
qu'on peut mettre mais il faut quand
même qu'il y en ait un petit peu donc on
peut nous aussi euh avoir certaines
exigences qui doivent être compatible
évidemment avec l'organisation d'une
compétition avec l'organisation d'un
match l'horaire le mais on doit tenir
compte aussi de notre avis on n'est pas
simplement là pour donner de l'argent et
et puis regarder écouter et obéir à ce
qu'on nous demande et ça c'est vrai que
on a parfois peut-être un peu de mal à
le à le faire passer moi je le terme
partenaire c'est vrai qu'on l'utilise
souvent mais à un moment nous sommes
aussi des clients nous payons pour un
produit qui est un
produit formidable mais le client peut
aussi parfois
d'avoir quelques exigences pour essayer
de rentabiliser un minimum cette cet
investissement oui reste cependant que
votre exigence concernant l'équipement
des stad pour la transmission de
télévision c'est pas avec votre client
que vous l'avez mais c'est avec le
partenaire de votre client qui
effectivement celui qui paye
l'équipement des stades à savoir les
collectivités territoriales et qui
participe en aucun cas à la discussion
dont vous faites état de savoir de
combien est le contrat que vous allez
payer pour pouvoir diffuser mais ça
c'est un problème d'organisation qui qui
pour le coup est un peu éloigné pour
nous je vais passer la parole à
Jean-Jacques losac
oui merci tout à l'heure le collègue
donnaé comme comme référence Arsenal je
crois effectivement que c'est un bon
exemple mais on pourrait parler me
semble-t-il aussi du Bayern Munich parce
qu'ils sont quand même champions
d'Europe leur budget est équilibré leur
télédépendance c'est simplement 22 % de
leur recette contre 56 % en France et
ils ont active politique de formation
des jeunes donc je crois que ça peut
être effectivement une référence
simplement deux questions mais la la
réponse peut être globalisée sur la la
procédure d'attribution des des droits
télévisés on a parfois l'impression à
tort ou à raison hein vous allez nous
donner votre votre sentiment votre
ressenti votre vécu on a parfois
l'impression que en matière de de
lisibilité de transparence de
compréhension on pourrait faire beaucoup
plus et beaucoup mieux je veux dire on
est sénateur mais on est aussi des élus
locaux et on voit notamment quelles sont
les contraintes auxquelles nous sommes
soumis au niveau du respect du code des
marchés publics qu'it des charges appel
d'offre confidentialité des documents
contrôle de l'égalité chambre régionale
des comptes et cetera on s'aperçoit que
dans la période récente en particulier
il y a quand même pas mal de
négociations notamment de gré à gré qui
entraînent parfois un certain nombre de
contestations hein je pense notamment au
droit du Top 14 par exemple est-ce que
vous avez pas le sentiment donc en terme
de de visibilité de clarté on pourrait
faire plus et et si oui quelle quelle
proposition serait les vôtres et une
deuxième question c'est sur la relation
donc sport professionnel et collectivité
territoriale les collectivités
territorial ell doivent essayer de
donner
satisfaction à tout un ensemble de
demandes qui sont quand même très
diversifiées je dirais il y a pas que le
foot et le rugby et donc on doit donner
satisfaction au maximum de pratiquants
ou de pratiquants potentiels et dans un
nombre toujours plus grand de sport bien
et euh je veux dire par là qu'on est
sensible très sensible à la
médiatisation du plus grand nombre de
sport possible parce que derrière la la
répartition de ces droits télévisé il y
a le financement du sport amateur et ça
nous concerne aussi nous collectivités
local parce qu'effectivement vous l'avez
dit il y a la taxe buffet il y a le CNDS
il y a les politiques des ligue
professionnelles ou des fédérations
sportives et cetera donc nous on a
intérêt à ce que le maximum de sport euh
soit soit médiatisé pour justement et
bien sur le plan territorial faire en
sorte qu'il ait le maximum de de
discipline qui qui qui qui se pratique
et je demande même si on n pas sur le le
moyen terme ou le long terme là des
intérêts communs hein c'est-à-dire
comment faire en sorte qu'il y ait
davantage de discipline médiatisé
qu'aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est une une
problématique qui euh euh qui vous vous
interpelle comme on dit et si oui là
aussi est-ce que vouses avez des
propositions à faire est-ce qu'il faut
en passer par des des procédures plus
plus contraignantes qu'aujourd'hui pour
essayer de d'élargir justement cette
palette de sport qui pour certains reste
quand même anonyme mais si vous voulez
on peut commencer par la fin surtout je
crois j'ai cru comprendre qu'on voulait
dans notre pays essayer de de de
supprimer un certain nombre de
contraintes administratives avec un
droit du travail qui fait 3000 pages
essayons de pas en ajouter en sport je
pense que ce serait préférable parce que
il y a un adage qui est faux c'est
diffusion égale audience ça alors c'est
c'est c'est faux faux et et ça sera
éternellement faux parce que il y a des
sports qui sont naturellement plus
marginaux que d'autres ne serait-ce que
par leur compréhension le cyclisme est
un sport simple le premier qui passe la
ligne d'arrivée il a gagné au football
tout le monde peut comprendre le
résultat d'un match desrp moi avant
qu'on me dise que la lumière s'allume
j'ai pas forcément tout de suite compris
qui avait gagné au judo je sais pas tout
de suite suivi qui avait gagné le match
il y a des choses qui sont je vous parle
pas du tir à la carabine à 10 m en
zigzag ou des choses comme ça donc il y
a des choses qui sont plus marginales
que d'autres il faut l'accepter il faut
l'accepter hein et surtout là il y a eu
des projets par exemple il faudrait pas
que le million d'euros par exemple que
le ministère des Sports met à
disposition d'un certain nombre d' sport
pour se faire connaître soit rendu
obligatoire parce que d'abord ça
tomberait sur le service public
évidemment et deuxièmement je pense pas
que ce serait que ce serait rentable
comme opération ilut faut accompagner
des sports il faut accompagner nous nous
accompagnons Eurosport on en parle nous
accompagnons le football féminin à
éclore mais avec beaucoup de prudence
qure matchs par an la finale de la Coupe
de
France nous accompagnons le rugby
féminin nous faisons le tournoi des
sination du rugby féminin ça fait pas
une audience on on considérable mais
nous accompagnons ce sport pour le reste
y a s'il y a un groupe de télévision qui
n'a pas à à à se faire de reproches la
promotion des sports olympiques c'est
bien c'est c'est bien le nôtre avec les
femmes et les hommes qui sont mis au au
même niveau ça je crois que là il faut
faire très attention à ça ne créons pas
de de contrainte qui serait dommageable
le seul regret que je puisse avoir moi
c'est que euh le
CNOSF qui a voulu monter une télévision
des sports olympiques il y a maintenant
2 ans les confier d'abord l'état n'a pas
notre actionnaire nous a pas autorisé à
concourir parce qu'il n'a jamais voulu
que le service public quelle que soit la
majorité de gauche ou de droite ne
possède une chaîne de sport ce qui
aurait changé pas mal de choses
notamment pour la promotion de certains
sports plus marginaux que d'autres il y
a un an il y a eu une chaîne de sport
qui a été montée elle ça a échoué à
l'équipe 21 c'était une chaîne qui
devait promouvoir les sport olympique et
j'y vois beaucoup plus de match de rugby
et de football que de vol à voile ou que
de canoé kayak bref alors que nous nous
avions proposé sur Internet une chaîne
des sports
olympiques où les sports marginaux
auraient pu venir s'exprimer don Tacte
ça c'est le passé pour ce qui concerne
la clarté des droits là c'est beaucoup
plus simple croyez-moi aujourd'hui dans
un pays comme le nôtre je parlais tout à
l'heure de la plus mauvaise date de
l'histoire de France croyez-moi on est
très notarial quand vous voyez un appel
d'OB de la Fédération française de
football ou de la Ligue professionnelle
de football croyez-moi ça laisse pas
beaucoup place à la discussion dans un
sur un coin de table il y a deux façons
il y a deux façons de faire il y a cette
façonl avec un appel d'offre publique
vous recevez le le le bouquin qui
regroupe les
désidératas de de la ligue ou de la
fédération en question et vous avez de
vous avez deux réponse ce qu'on appelle
une enveloppe qualitative la qualité de
votre produit et quantitative qui se
résume au chèque que vous mettez donc on
étudie et c'est une c'est une
péréquation entre les deux vous pouvez
avec une note plus forte en qualitatif
par exemple une meilleure exposition de
la compétition l'emporter sur un chèque
un peu plus gros mais une moins bonne
exposition voilà comment ça se passe
pour le reste il y a une autre façon de
faire qui est la consultation du marché
c'est-à-dire un vendeur consulte
l'ensemble croyez-moi il a intérêt à
consulter l'ensemble des des des des
acheteurs potentiels sinon il a il a une
il a une affaire sur le dos dans le dans
la dans la semaine qui suit il y a
quelques années par exemple il y a 5 6
ans la Ligue de Football
Professionnel voulait vendre la Coupe de
la Ligue comme le championnat de France
est entièrement privatisé voulait la
vendre dans son appel d'offre avait s
avait stipulé que c'était réservé à une
chaîne gratuite et bien canal plus à
attaquer non pas parce que ça les
intéressait mais pour pour faire en
sorte que le principe ne puisse pas être
établi que des que des que des acheteurs
soit écarté d'un marché donc ils ont
fait annuler on est obligé de refaire
l'appel d'offre ils n'ont pas concouru
pas plus la première fois que la seconde
mais ils ont fait établir les chose donc
il y asol absolument rien surtout
maintenant j'allais dire avec l'arrivée
avec l'arrivée qui a changé la nature du
marché le marché français c'était un
marché j'allais dire on avait échappé à
la mondialisation des droits avant
l'arrivée de be avant d'arriv d'aljazira
c'est-à-dire qu'un vendeur pouvait
vendre cher très cher à mon ami à droite
à Eurosport à France Télévision à M6 à
la marge parce qu'ils achètent
relativement peu de choses alors
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez une
multinationale que représente Florent et
qui est venu s'installer dans notre pays
donc le marché a complètement changé la
nature du marché a complètement changé
et et et c'est là où la difficulté des
chaînes nationales par rapport à des par
rapport à une multinational elle est
dans d'autres secteurs de l'économie la
difficulté de PME de finalement de ce
que nous sommes des PME par rapport à
une multinationale C'est ça la vraie et
aujourd'hui croyez-moi BeIn Sport est un
acheteur comme les autres qui surveille
de très près les marchés qui ne
s'arrange pas plus que les autres et la
légalité des la légalité des des ventes
de droit elle est alors là je peux vous
le
dire 100 % une une réalité il y a
absolument aucune alors il s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé là sur le le Top 14
euh mais si vous
voulez le vendeur n'avait pas été très
correct avec Canal plus parce que il
avait mis sur la place
publique le prix de la prolongation de
contrat différent de la renouvellement
de la prolongation de contrat qu'il
proposait l'avait rendu publicque donc
il suffisait un autre acheteur de mettre
10 centimes d'euros de plus pour
l'emporter finalement ils se sont
arrangés mais en même temps cette
fois-ci c'est bein qui peut très bien
attaquer en disant qu'ils ont été
écartés du marché parce que là
finalement l'accord ne s'est pas fait
sur une simple prolongation mais sur une
durée réelle de
contrat ce est complètement différent et
là effectivement il y a matière il y a
matière peut-être moi si j'étais juriste
il y a peut-être matière à à à contester
C cet accord là mais croyez-moi il y a
pas de il y a pas de j'allais pas dire
malheureusement mais il y a pas de il y
a pas de combine possible
heureusement pour rebondir sur ce que
dit pardon pour rebondir sur ce que dit
Daniel sur l'arrivée de bein parce que
ça a fait beaucoup parler bein est un
groupe qatari un groupe de télé
international ils ne sont pas arrivés il
y a 20 mois pour faire de la télé en
France c'est un groupe qui est déployé
au niveau international et qui est venu
investir en France pour et là on parle
de télé et de sport pour créer deux
chaînes de sport qui sont des chaînes
qui ne sont pas des chaînes de
compléments mais qui sont
complémentaires des chaînes amis comme
France Télévision comme Eurosport ou TF1
qui diffuse et on s'entend très bien
avec l'ensemble des chaînes qui
diffusent des événements qui sont
complémentaires moi je pose une question
tout à l'heure vous parliez de l'exemple
d'Arsenal ou l'exemple du Bayern en
disant que les droits à l'étranger
sont largement supérieurs en France il
faut aussi juste se rendre compte qu'à
l'étranger au niveau du paysage
audiovisuel il y a beaucoup de
concurrence en France on a tendance à ne
pas vouloir et ne pas accepter la
concurrence et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
je pose une question si be n'était pas
arrivé il y a 20 mois en France quelle
aurait été aujourd'hui la valeur du
championnat de France de Ligue 1 avec un
seul diffuseur qui met sur la table le
chèque et la le montant qu'il a envie de
on n serait même pas là en train de
parler de 600 ou 700 millions d'euros on
serait peut-être à parler de deux fois
moins trois fois moins puisqu'il y a une
une situation de monopole et c'est le
diffuseur qui fixe son prix dans un
premier temps je pense que l'intérêt du
sport français de l'ensemble des
diffuseurs c'est d'avoir une certaine
concurrence avec évidemment une certaine
valeur d'un d'un d'un d'un d'une
compétition ce qu'on appelle le juste
prix parce que c'est l'intérêt de tout
le monde sinon c'est de la vision à
court terme on assèche une compétition
et la valeur d'un championnat les
joueurs s'en vont ça vaut plus rien plus
personne n'achète votre abonnement et au
final tout le monde est perdant donc je
veux juste retracer là parce
qu'effectivement parfois en France on a
un peu tendance à pas souvent regarder
l'arrivée et voir l'arrivée
d'investisseurs étrangers que ce soit
dans des clubs de foot ou au niveau de
la télé comme quelque chose de de
positif je pose cette question et je
j'attire l'attention de tout le monde en
disant quand on compare avec l'étranger
il faut vraiment regarder ce qui se fait
à l'étranger il y a énormément de
concurrence au niveau des diffuseurs qui
font parfois monter les droits euh
troput trop haut ça c'est sûr mais qu'il
faut trouver un juste milieu et en
France aujourd'hui la situation actuelle
on a réussi on est sur un format qui est
je pense satisfaisant pour tout le monde
dans l'état actuel des choses je sais
pas si mes collègues sont d'accord juste
pour juste pour compléter je crois que
l'arrivée de BeIn Sport sur le marché
français elle a finalement conduit à à
une chose c'est d'avoir deux offres
aujourd'hui sur le marché une offre du
payant et une offre du gratuit et comme
le disait Daniel tous les sports ne sont
pas éligibles pour des audiences
euh fédératrices familiales comme on
peut les avoir sur une chaîne comme
France 2 comme TF1 où on a une certaine
obligation de rassembler plusieurs
millions de téléspectateurs devant un
événement donc il y a des sports ou des
événements comme la Coupe du Monde comme
les Joos qui sont éligibles pour des
grandes chaînes comme TF1 ou France
Télévision et puis il y a des sports ou
des compétitions récurrentes qui sont
aujourd'hui faites pour le marché du
payant et qui permettent à canal ou à
bein d'exposer aussi d'autres sport
d'autres compétitions pour les fanas
pour les les les supporters de club et
qui vont prendre un abonnement pour ça
donc il faut bien avoir en tête que les
diffuseurs aujourd'hui sont organisés en
deux marchés distincts complémentaires
qui malheureusement on fait aussi un peu
exploser les droits qui aussi il faut le
il faut le dire sont
peut-être un inconvénient pour le
téléspectateur qui aimerait de temps en
temps avoir l'occasion de regarder un
match de ligue des champions avec le
parisint-germain qui est passé de TF1 au
tout payant euh ou voir un grand prix de
Formule 1 qui là aussi est passé du du
gratuit au payant mais c'est le marché
qui veut ça aujourd'hui il faut juste
permettre à nos téléspectateurs grâce
aux brefs extraits qui sont autorisés
dans certaines émissions euh d'avoir
accès quand même à un minimum de résumés
ou alors au au JT on le voit dans nos
dans nos éditions du 1h du 20h on expose
aussi des sports confidentiels il n'y a
pas que les événements qui vont donner
de l'exposition à un sport méconnu ou
peu connu donc voilà je je pense qu'il
faut vraiment avoir en tête ces deux
équilibres aujourd'hui du paysage ça a
reconstruit un peu le paysage en France
il y avait un paysage uniquement centré
sur le gratuit autour de de canal
aujourd'hui voilà il y a du gratuit du
payant et un bon équilibre je pense qui
qui s'est installé Rachel Mair oui juste
un petit mot parce qu'on a parlé de
devant c'est de modèle économique et on
a comparé avec l'Angleterre si j'ai bien
compris beaucoup
l'Allemagne il y a une différence
essentielle c'est que les stades sont
pleins dans tous les cas hein à Londres
il y a combien de clubs TR qu qu oui à
Madrid il y en a trois qui étaient dans
le top dans le chez nous je regrette
mais les stades sont pas toujours pleins
et je ne parle pas de Monaco hein donc
il y a aussi un moment pas forcément que
je vais pas vous voler à votre secours
mais un modèle économique s'appuie sur
des réalités économique et la réalité
économique du football français
aujourd'hui elle est pas la même ni en
qu'en Angleterre qu'en Espagne ou au
Real Madrid dès l'instant où l'enfant
est né on l'inscrit comme sociaux du
Real ou du Barcelone je veux dire il y a
une démarchees complètement différentes
alors ça veut pas dire qu'il faut que
vous donniez moins d'argent c'est pas ça
mais je me dis il y a des il y a des
schémas qui sont complètement différents
en Allemagne c'est plein les stades sont
pleins même si les gens sont les les
clubs sont en passe de descendre chez
nous chez nous en même temps comme vous
dites à Monaco c'est les joueurs qui
connaissent le nom des spectateur c'est
l'inverse
mais comment dirais-je faites attention
à une chose aussi nous heureusement on a
il y a quand même puisquon est un pays
de contrôle he on a la DNCG qui
contrôle les financement des clubs
peut-être que si en Espagne il y avait
la DNCG on n serait pas là où on est
attention ils sont en situation de
faillite alors je sais pas comment ils
survivent et cetera et cetera en plus
quelles sont les mesenes qui acceptent
mais il faut reconnaître au football
français qu'il est relativement il y a
du déficite mais il est relativement
bien géré et contrôlé par un organisme
chargé moi je pense qu'il y a il faut
tout à l'heure je je disais avec
l'évolution du du sport professionnel il
faut s'inspirer de ce que font les
Américains les Américains sont sont ce
sont les les rois du du capitalisme du
libre échange sauf qu'on voulait vendre
des choses chez eux hein vous savez
aussi bien que moi hein à ce momentlà
ils sont beaucoup plus réservés que pour
vendre à l'extérieur mais le leur sport
entre les ligues les ligues fermées et
le salar cap c'est-à-dire la limitation
des salaires ils font une gestion du
sport professionnel qui est quand même
beaucoup plus rationnelle que la nôtre
si en Europe on faisait une législation
sur les salaires des joueurs sur
l'ensemble des salaires on aurait sans
doute moins de problèmes de déf cite on
aurait sans doute plus de régularité et
l'égalité entre les clubs les Américains
font ça très bien et que je sache le
sport aux États-Unis n'est pas en
difficulté donc deux choses un Lig
fermée c'est peut-être pas très très
très romantique mais c'est comme ça donc
ce sont des magasins ils sont ouverts ou
ils ferment parce qu'ils ne vendent pas
assez de de de match et ils vendent pas
assez de de de sponsoring et
ensuite la répartition des salaires la
salariecable ça éviterait ce qu'on
entend et ce qui pe moi personnellement
peut m'pparaître re choquant quand même
et qui je pense dans un pays comme le
nôtre par rapport à des millions de gens
à quelque chose honnêtement à quelque
chose de à quelque chose de choquant
donc je pense que là si au niveau
européen les les gouvernements se metit
d'accord c'est facile à mettre c'est
facile à mettre en
place Michel de Messine oui ben c'est
c'est justement ce ce que je voulais
dire la réflexion parce que on vous sent
un pe un peu à cran c'est pas pas
toujours comme ça que rou nos auditions
mais c'est aussi parce que vous êtes
souvent sur la
Cellette je comprends parfaitement et
justement par rapport au à laadcion nous
avons je sais pas si la solution passe
par plus d'argent dans le foot et plus
plus de droit télé parce que à un moment
donné quand même ces masses d'argent
dans dans le sport et dans le foot ça ça
ça pose problème d'autant que le
problème il est pas dans les droits télé
pour moi il est dans le salaire des
joueurs parce que c'est c'est là qui est
c'est là qu'aboutit
l'essentiel de l'argent et on en est à
des niveaux qui deviennent
inimaginables mais non mais même même
inimaginable à quoi ça sert quoi
franchement donc c'était pour recibler
un petit peu notre discussion sur ce
point-là mais vous venez de le faire
donc je sais pas si c'est le modèle
américain qui qu'il faut qu'il faut
choisir mais peu importe en tout cas je
pense qu' il y a une réaction à avoir
alors c'est vrai que dans les autres
pays européens comme c'est bien au-delà
de nous et qui se pose pas toutes ces
questions parce que les équilibres se
font différemment mais en raison
justement ce qui était dit de
l'engouement on n'est pas dans le même
pays il y a un engouement beaucoup plus
fort en Angleterre on le sent bien de
toute façon donc ça c'est c'est c'est
notre pays comme ça je pense qu' il faut
s'adapter à ça donc je pense que faut
plus cibler sur la question ce qu'on le
pose pas assez souvent ce problème qui
est celui des ser du joueur alors je
vais faire une deuxième remarque mais
qui est pas du tout là-dessus d'ailleurs
euh je je n'ai pas not normalement à
répondre au président aux questions du
président puisque je fais partie des
questionneurs mais puisqu'on a parlé du
stade de lîle tout à l'heure je ne peux
pas m'empêcher de faire une remarque si
vous le
permettez euh en en disant que
effectivement on peut pas faire de
d'équipements multifonctionnels partout
comme ça euh et qu'il faut d'abord il y
a des conditions à remplir c'estd au
niveau des territoires il faut qui a des
zones de chalandis qui permettent
vraiment un modèle comme celui-là donc
évidemment comment on peut réguler ça
c'est la vraie question faut le réguler
et en même temps disons-nous même si on
a beaucoup de doutes sur le modèle
disons-nous que c'est un prototype pour
l'instant qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas
habitué on sait pas encore bien faire
mais que mais il faut pas décourager je
je voudrais pas enterrer le modèle je
vis pas qu'on enterre le modèle sur ces
balbuements je pense qu'il faut lui
donner la chance de réussir il faut du
temps il faut du temps pour euh euh pour
construire une nouvelle activité qui
n'existe pas dans notre pays mais je
pense
que on a toutes les toutes les
possibilités de réussir évidemment euh
euh dans la multifonctionnalité euh
forcément le sport reste dominateur euh
c'est
pas ce sera que quelques quelques
spectacles ce sera jamais euh euh ça
c'est du du plus mais quand même euh
pour le territoire et puis pour l'équipe
lui-même qu'il puisse servir à autre
chose que le sport et ne pas vivre
uniquement tous les 15 jours sur des si
gros investissements moi je trouve que
ça vaut le coup d'essayer tout à fait
d'accord je dis juste que voilà c'est
encore faut-il avoir des des spectacles
des artistes capables de les remplir
voilà juste sur sur je voulais revenir
sur le sur le financement si vous le
permettez je pense en fait on a on a
quelque part ici entre nous dans la
discussion donner une partie de la
réponse on peut pas être dépendant d'un
seul financement c'est trop dangereux
c'est vrai d'un financement étranger
même si c'est très bien qu'il y a des
financements étrangers qui viennent
aider le football français mais du jour
au lendemain un riball au fleff à Monaco
pour X raisons peut décider de se
désengager qu'est-ce qui va se passer
euh on a le cas de lance aussi avec les
azérriis hein le club de lance donc qui
qui qui pourra on espère pour pour ce
club et pour ses supporters si euh si
engagés si engagés qu'il puisse
retrouver la la Ligue 1 donc un
financement étranger soit euh mais
dépend uniquement de ça c'est dangereux
les droits télé bah après il y a une
réalité quoi c'està-dire qu'il y a aussi
quel est le marché en face qui est prêt
à payer quel est le nombre de personnes
qui sont prêts à payer pour avoir un
abonnement télé ça c'est une vraie
question c'est pas c'est pas extensible
à l'infini dans les ménages maintenant
on le voit bien on l' vu encore plus
avec la crise quand vous devz payer les
mobiles des enfants les abonnements
Internet et cetera et cetera pour vous
abonner sur une chaîne supplémentaire de
de sport ah benah c'est quand même c'est
quand même c'est quand même pas évident
surtout qu'il y a d'autres phénomènes
qui sont le piratage même si c'est
encore pas à la même échelle que qu'
qu'on a pu vivre sur la musique mais
quand même c'est aussi des des des
choses qu'il faut qu'il faut regarder
donc le marché n'est pas extensible et
les droits télé se reposent
essentiellement sur un équilibre
économique que nous aussi on peut y
trouver donc ça c'est quand même
important de de le dire je v aussi
rajouter quelque chose sur la diversité
des sports évidemment Eurosport on y est
très attaché en fait Eurosport quelque
part on a le cœur d'un service public et
le portefeuille d'une chaîne privée on
est un peu entre les deux on s'est
toujours construit comme ça avec je l'ai
dit au départ avec la multidiscipline
avec une chaîne qui est peu chè puisque
c'est quelques C quelques dizaines de
centimes d'euros pour la pour la baudé
donc ça ça n'a rien à voir avec le prix
de canal ça av rien à voir avec le prix
de bein on propose pas les mêmes types
de produits c'est complémentaire mais
donc j'insiste aussi pour dire et pour
faire passer le message que le rôle
d'Eurosport est important par rapport à
ça c'est parce qu'on est capable par
cette accessibilité aussi de développer
des disciplines et de les montrer au
plus grand nombre euh parce que euh et
je rejoins aussi ce que ce que disait ce
que disait
Daniel on remplit pas ber avec un club
de jazz avec un groupe de jazz c'est pas
possible pourtant le jazz c'est une
musique noble aussi noble qu'on puisse
imaginer mais voilà vous avez différents
types de de sport qui nont des capacités
ou pas de remplir des salles plus ou
moins grandes donc des chaînes avec un
potentiel de visibilité plus plus ou
moins important un autre élément aussi
parfois que je je voudrais corriger je
vous remercie il a pas été évoqué ici
mais qu'on entend souvent c'est dire les
gratuits c'est les gentils les méchants
c'est les payants parce que on enlève le
sport du gratuit pour le mettre on prive
en fait un certain nombre de de de
personnes qui aiment le sport du sport
n'oublions pas tout ce que font les
chaînes payantes parce que c'est dans
leur leur modèle économique pour créer
de la valeur autour du sport pour faire
monter des disciplines pour faire monter
des compétitions on a cité l'exemple de
de canal sur ce qu'il a fait ce que
Canal a fait sur le football si la Ligue
1 en est là aujourd'hui c'est aussi il
faut quand même le reconnaître pourtant
c'est un concurrent donc je le dis tout
à fait librement c'est aussi grâce à
canal grâce à ce qu'a fait canal ce
qu'on est en train de développer sur
laad1 féminine on le fait parce que
c'est notre intérêt de créer de la
valeur de la D1 féminine pour demain que
la D féminine deviennent prescriptif
d'abonnement que des annonceurs puissent
s'y intéresser on n'est pas dans une
logique de coût Cup ou de ou de ou
d'événementiel le gratuit et c'est
naturelchchettera toujours l'événement
fédérateur ou ce qui faudra ce qui fera
que il va pouvoir rassembler le plus
grand nombre ou utiliser de temps en
temps le sport comme un accélérateur de
notoriété et de puissance comme
certaines chaînes de la dintégr suite
mais ne sera pas dans une logique de
construction ceux qui vont construire le
sport ce seront les chaînes payantes
alors après à nous de gérer un certain
d'équilibre n à Eurosport on est très
attentif à mettre autant
d'investissement dans le tennis le
cyclisme les sport mécanique football
rugby les sports aussi divers olympique
et les sports d'été à nous de de
préserver ça mais je voulais quand même
insister pour pour pour dire que le
modèle Eurosport à cette particularité
d'être un peu entre de la chaîne payante
super premium cher et qui va proposer
des très beaux produits mais qui
fondamentalement va se concentrer qu'on
le veut non sur le football le top
football et le et le top Ruby pour
parler de la France et les chaînes
gratuites qui seront dans l'événement
ciel pur ce qui est tout à fait légitime
donc notre rôle à nous il est là aussi
dans la construction dans le
développement dans le dans la visibilité
dans l'accessibilité Françoise
be merci monsieur le
Président je souhaiterais vous poser une
question enfin plus particulièrement
monsieur Simon et
ouo euh donc peut-être que vous l'avez
évoqué en en début de réunion mais je
suis arrivée en retard j'étais retenue
par une autre réunion au sein du Sénat
et je vous prie de m'en excuser est-ce
que les sports un peu moins populaires
plus
confidentiels pour qui intéresse un
public plus restreint est-ce que là les
fédérations nationales internationales
voir les promoteurs sont dans le cas
inverse et payent les télés pour être
retransmis
une excellente question oui ça arrive ça
arrive c'est par exemple nous un accord
qu'on a avec la Fédération
internationale des Sports universitaires
la
FISU qui voit en Eurosport notamment
avec sa plateforme européenne la
capacité de développer ces compétitions
et donc on a un accord avec eux de type
commercial mais aussi éditorial
d'accompagnement de direct effectivement
c'est des modèles qu'on
peut qu'on peut qu'on voit se se
développer
ça concerne plutôt des petites
disciplines et c'est pas idiot c'est pas
idiot parce que ça leur permet aussi de
mettre le pied à l'étrier d'avoir une
exposition d'exister et de pouvoir créer
un modèle aussi vertueux avec leurs
partenaires sponsor avec les villes qui
peuvent accueillir les événements donc
oui oui c'est c'est quelque chose qui
qui
existe je sais pas si au niveau de non
on a pas cet exemple là on est par
contre sur effectivement la vitrine
principale qui est compétition premium
de football euh mais aussi puisque
c'était la volonté affichée d'entrée
avant même que la chaîne se lance de ne
pas être seulement une chaîne de
football mais une chaîne omnisport et
aujourd'hui le catalogue de des 15
disciplines qui sont proposées sur bin
le le démontre avec pas mal
d'investissements et de retour sur des
droits pour certains clubs de basket je
le disais tout à l'heure avec nanter et
Strasbourg mais aussi handball puisqu'on
diffus les compétitions d'unkererque du
parisaingermain handball de Nant de
Chambéry de Montpellier et les fil mes
en Ligue des Champions c'est c'est sur
BeIn Sport on diffuse également la super
liue de rugby à 13 avec l'équipe des 13
catalan qu'on on paye des droits on paye
de la production là-dessus et on diffuse
l'ensemble de la saison on diffuse
l'ensemble des compétitions de de judo
international Les Grands Prix les grands
schlem les championnats du monde les
meetings de d'athlétisme Diamond League
on a même répondu et ça je sais que
Daniel est souvent
sollicité sur ce genre de de démarche de
fédération qui sollicite un diffuseur
pour obtenir au sein d'une fédération
internationale l'an l'organisation d'un
événement en France ça a été le cas
début janvier de la Fédération Française
de volleyball qui nous a sollicité en
nous demandant de vouloir être
producteur et diffuseur du tournoi de
qualif de qualification pour les
championnats du monde qui auront lieu en
septembre au Pologne parce que le fait
de jouer en France est un avantage pour
eux on a donc répondu favorablement à
cette demande qui a donc pu permettre à
à la France de porter sa candidature à
l'organisation de ce tournoi qui a eu
lieu début janvier à Paris qu'on a
produit qu'on a diffusé l'équipe de
France s'est qualifiée elle ira donc au
championnat du monde en septembre
prochain donc voilà il y a pas que la
vitrine principale le football euh où
les droits sont chers mais il y a aussi
tout un tas de sports euh qu'on diffuse
on a diffusé et produit euh en 2013 un
certain nombre de championnats du monde
et championnat d'Europe de de boxeurs
français euh voilà sans oublier
évidemment la dernière acquisition avec
le championnat du monde de de handball
masculin et féminin dont l'édition de en
2017 de l'équipe
de masculin aura Liu en France donc là
c'est pareil c'est j'ai le souvenir
Daniel s'en souviendra aussi que là on
revient à l'approche d'un diffuseur et
le côté diffuseur et aspect de
production un souvenir concernant les
championnats du monde de ski à valdizer
où évidemment France Télé avait répondu
favorablement à l'époque à à la à la
production de cet événement donc
l'attribution par la féd internationale
de ski de cet événement et Daniel a reçu
un matin sur son bureau la proposition
qui était déjà fermé définitive de
partir sur deux sites et deux et deux
pistes distinctes et les gens qui
avaient imaginé ça ne n'avaient
évidemment pas imaginé qu'en terme de
production c'était x 2 et donc c'est
vrai que quand on est diffuseur et que
on découvre ça à quelques mois d'un
événement et qu'on a budgetté tant de
droit et tant de frais de production et
on parle pas de 500 € on parle de
millions d'euros quand il faut
multiplier par deux la le budget de de
production c'est mais ça c'est des
choses que les gens les les les
fédérations les les les
clubs le pouvoir politique ne ne peut
pas donc de temps en temps c'est aussi
bien de de rappeler ce genre de chos
parce que ce sont des paramètres
important et comment c'est vous les
méchant ouais je pense pas qu'on soit
les méchants une réalité c'est que il
faut partir du principe que je pe
comprendre beaucoup de gens pensent
qu'on en fait pas assez le problème
c'est vous savez le problème du sport le
problème de la télévision vous pouvez
faire de la radio en ayant du talent
sans argent avant d'avoir du talent à la
télévision faut avoir de l'argent parce
qu'avant de vous dire bonjour J'ai déjà
pour 20000 € de DF
donc voilà le talent à la télévision ne
sert à rien ne sert à rien si vous
n'avez pas d'argent il y y a il y a pas
il y a pas ça n'existe pas il y a des la
radio c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire moi en sortant d'ici je
vais aller RTL pour un pour un quelqu'un
va téléphoner de Kief ça va lui
coûter 40 € de de téléphone moi si je
fais un direct de de Kief à la
télévision j'en ai pour des des 15000 €.
ben c'est tout c'est c'est ça donc donc
il faut faut faut vous rendre compte que
nous pour nous tout est une question
d'argent tout est une question
d'argent après l'éditorial c'est après
mais si si vous n'avez pas d'argent
c'est pas la peine de vous lancer dans
une affaire comme celle-ci c'est c'est
c'est complètement inutile là je sors
des des Jeux Olympiques divhivers nous
avons 2 personnes ont travaillé sur ce
sur ce produit ça fait 2 ans que nous le
préparons actuellement nous sommes en
train de finir la préparation des Jeux
olympiques de Rio entre la logistique la
technique et cetera et ça ce sont des
millions et des millions d'euros alors
la particul du service public c'est que
par rapport au privé dont les exploits
sont toujours relatés nous on est un peu
comme le DF hein quand le type appuie
sur le bouton ça s'allume c'est normal
puis voudrait pas en plus qu'on les
remercie déjà nous quand on nous dit
rien on considère que c'est le plus beau
des compliments si voilà on est comme la
SNCF c'està-dire le train arrive à leur
pile le gars dit et et vous avez entendu
avec l'exagération aujourd'hui par exle
quand il y a 2hur de retard les TI parl
de leur traversée terrible parce qu'il y
a 2hures de retard à l'arrivée à la gare
de Lyon hein franchement pendant 2hur
ils ont la télévision public c'est c'est
ça c'est c'est la régularité fait que
les gens trouvent tout à fait normal que
que on allum la télé il ce qu'ils ont
envie d'avoir quel que soit l'heure de
la nuit pour vous vous parlez tout à
l'heure des des certains qui payaient
pour passer non nous nous ne faisons pas
ça en revanche sur des choses qui ne
nous semblent pas suffisamment
intéressantes ou qui nous semblent pas
obligatoire de payer parce que nous
n'avons pas de concurrents nous
n'achetons pas en terme de droit mais
nous produisons c'est-à-dire nous payons
d'une certaine façon par exemple le
patinage qui est un sport qui est qui
est en j' vaais dire en chute libre sauf
aux Jeux Olympiques nous faisons deux
galas de patinage par an pour essayer
d'aider le le patinage à survivre et
bien nous ne les payons pas mais nous
les produisons ce qui est une manière de
de de de payer et et vous avez en fait
on est dans une situation où je dis
avant la la la course poursuite des prix
et la la BAGAR était entre les gratuits
parce que les payants
étaient très peu nombreux canal plus
Eurosport est sur un modèle très
différent mais canal plus était seul en
France au titre de vrai payant l'arrivée
de BeIn Sport fait que le combat des
droits s'est déplacé
du gratuit vers le payant il y a
pratiquement plus de bataille entre les
groupes les groupes gratuits d'abord
parce qu'ils ont des contraintes
économiques extrêmement
importante deuxièmement
euh je dirais qu'ils ont ils font des
choix qui les qui qui sont obligés de
faire pour aller vers une télévision
différente donc nous ne conservons plus
TF1 et nous nous ne conservons plus
encore nous nous conservons plus de
choses parce que nous sommes un service
public au sens propre du terme mais à la
limite des des chaînes comme les nôtres
les ne devrait ne devrait plus faire
aujourd'hui que des événements de sport
on en parlait au début de la rencontre
et les événements de sport ils sont
relativement peu nombreux c'est l'équipe
de France de rugby c'est l'équipe de
France de football c'est le tour de
France parce que le Tour de France c'est
un moment de joie simple entre Français
ça n'a rien à voir avec le sport je veux
dire les les gens qui regardent le Tour
de France pour expliquer que tout le
monde est drogué ils s'en fichent
complètement c'est quand même l'occasion
une fois par an de redécouvrir leur pays
de s'apercevoir qu'il y a pas que des
autoroutes et des des McDonald's mais
les routes à deux voies avec des églises
et des choses comme ça qu'ils avaient
ignoré complètement
euh c'est un événement de de de joie
simple là voilà et puis Roland Garros
encore que l'affaire de Roland Garros ne
soit pas si simple à
régler voilà donc pour cette table ronde
organisée par la mission commune
d'information sur le sport professionnel
et les collectivités territorial table
ronde donc consacré à la diffusion du
sport parallèlement à toutes ces
auditions et bien la mission commeune
d'information sur le sport professionnel
continue ses déplacements en Europe à la
pu notamment se rendre dans de grands
clubs européens comme Arsenal en
Angleterre ou encore au Bayern de Munich
pour pouvoir ainsi comparer la situation
en France et en Europe vous pouvez bien
sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site sur
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 19h pour 24h Sénat présenté par
Delphine Girard très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires